good evening
uh before the meeting commences i would
like everyone present to join with me
in a two-minute silence as we pay
tributes and honor and remember those
who have lost their lives in conflict
whilst fighting to protect our freedom
you will remain in place or stand for
two minutes
thank you um
interrupt of the speakers members are
reminded not to use the messaging
or chat function during the meeting
unless it's to report a pecuniary or
non-binary interest
or to notify the chair that you wish to
make a proposal
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair
please await your turn if members lose
connection of the meeting
that they must contact that you must
contact the member support officer mandy
smith
as soon as possible to rejoin as this is
a virtual meeting you will not need to
stand
to address the chair i'd like to remind
everyone present that this meeting
will be broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeating viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed
by the council to have consented to
being filmed
by entering this meeting you're also
consenting to being filmed
by the council and of the possible use
of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence
thank you chair i've received apologies
for absence from councillor ebern
thank you and i'm sure i echo the
sentiments of all councillors
in wishing uh the very best as she goes
forward
i'll now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to take a
roll call for the members present
thank you chair um counselor amarosan
present counselor brewster present
that's the burn
present councillor flatman president
ansler fleming present councillor geek
present councillor gould present
councillor guthrie present councillor
hattingham
president councillor hicks president
councillor humphreys
present councillor mansell present
councillor matheson president councillor
mellon
present councilman mayor president
that's normally president councillor
muller
present councillor norris president
council often
present that's the passmore present
that's the phillips
cancer phillips
i think there's a uh dick he declined
the invite
so okay technology okay thank you
cancer pratt present cancer richardson
present cancer scarf present cancer
stringer
present cancer turner present cancer war
boys
present councillor wellam present
councillor whitehead
president thank you
thank you um declaration of interest by
councillors
um under section 31 of the local
localism act
2011 all members have been granted
dispensation by the monitoring officer
for all matters relating to the local
plan therefore councillors do not need
to declare
any inter any interest under this item
are there any other declarations of
interest
okay there are none i'd like to invite
the councillor byrne to moving on sorry
to mc
20-8 baber babera mid-suffolk draft
joint local plan and statement of
community involvement addendum
i'd like to invite councillor byrne to
introduce paper mc208
and to move the recommendations and
reports and i note that your video
isn't working uh but we can hear you
councillor bern
well thank you sherman um
this evening i'm presenting to you our
new draft
joint local plan or jlp to give it its
familiar title
earlier today i was thinking of it as
one thinks about an iceberg
with only 10 of of which is visible
on the surface but our jlp is even more
impressive than that
because the 610 pages that constitute
the plan that we see
is just six percent of its overall
volume
supporting it under the surface are more
than 10 200 pages
of evidence base this is more evidence
than we have ever had
to back up a local plan and it has
involved our staff
in a massive amount of work in recent
months
it has presented huge challenges to meet
the timetable
that we set in our local development
scheme approved earlier this year
as the chairman's just pointed out paper
mc20 still eight
refers and i will address some of the
key points in it
you will see that at paragraph 1.1 and
the recommendations at 3.1
and and that i will be asking you to
approve
the regulation 19 pre-submission
document
and submit it to the secretary of state
for
an independent examination a six-week
period on the legal
compliance and soundness of the plan is
proposed to run
from the 12th of november until the 24th
of december
during this period representations from
stakeholders and other interested
parties are invited
but this is not a consultation where we
would
where we would subsequently make changes
to our plan
responses must be made in writing and if
duly made will simply be sent to the
planning inspector
for consideration in the examination
next year
when the examination process is
completed the plan will be returned to
us
for approval and formal adoption by the
councils
at paragraphs 1.3 paragraphs 4.1 to 4.3
and paragraphs 9.1 to 9.2
you will see the background stages in
the plan's production
starting with the decision in 2016
to prepare a joint plan for baba and
mid-suffolk
in 2017 we produced our first joint
local plan
consultation document seeking views
on a range of options and we received
some 14
000 responses they informed our
preferred options consultation
in 2019 with over 4 000 responses to
consider
before preparing the joint local plan
you have before you
at the same time the extensive evidence
base referred to a paragraph 4.4 was
being prepared
these documents are included in the
appendices detailed
at paragraph 12 and in the core document
library
a link for which is is in paragraph
13. section 2
of the report deals with the options
which are basically
that you approve this plan or you don't
if you choose not to submit this plan
but seek instead to reinterpret the
evidence that supports it
and make changes it may well have the
implica have implications as a result of
the government's proposed changes
to the current planning system you will
remember our debate in september
and the effect the changes could have on
our calculated housing need
you will also remember the transitional
arrangements proposed for authorities
at the stage we are in plan making
it is important to recognize that we
have a window of opportunity to submit
our plan
based on the existing calculation of
need
if we miss that window we may well have
to plan for significantly more homes
that would require a major revision of
the plan
with a new call for sites new assessment
and a likely delay measured in years
not weeks or months
in mid-suffolk the plan provides for 535
dwellings per year
or 10 200 dwellings by 2037.
around 3 800 of these dwellings already
have
planning permission so the plan is
allocating sites
to to to meet the remaining need
the approach to distributing these
dwellings has sought to balance growth
in line with the outcomes from our 2017
and 2019 consultation
we need to maintain a land supply
throughout the period of the plan
so we have included a 20 buffer as a
safeguard
in case some of the proposed sites don't
come forward
a key element of the evidence
underpinning the plan is the
infrastructure delivery plan which you
will have seen labeled as
eh08 in the core document library
there is a link to it in paragraph 13.1
as i've said
the idp proves
greater provides sorry greater detail on
infrastructure requirements than has
ever been provided before
including education health
transport emergency services utilities
digital connectivity waste and community
facilities
and green infrastructure
it identifies the need and sets out the
funding sources
including the community's infrastructure
levy
and time scales for delivery
we can have much greater confidence that
appropriate infrastructure will support
development than we have ever had before
i know there are many of you that will
be particularly pleased to see the
detail in some of the local policies
including lp06 and lp07
addressing supported and special needs
housing
lp 17 through to lp 21 seeking to
protect the environment
biodiversity landscape and heritage
lp 25 addressing sustainable
construction
and design these together with our
strategic policies
should guide our decisions towards
better development
in our district at paragraphs 9.3 to 9.8
you will see the next stages
if you approve the recommendations i'm
proposing today
they include briefings for town and
parish councils
and neighborhood plan groups
i'd like to finish by thanking some of
the people involved
now singling out individuals is often
manifestly unfair
but i will i will start with our
assistant director for sustainable
communities tom barker
and his various teams with the special
mention
for the strategic planning team who have
done so much of the detailed work
and to physic for this excuse me
phil isbell for the extra help his plan
has provided when we needed it
i should also like to thank clive arthy
the cabinet member for
planning at baber
for his commitment and shared ambition
to produce a plan
for both councils we have worked
together with the joint local plan
member working group
to assess and review the developing plan
in accordance with the evidence base
and taking into account the
representations received
following last year's consultation
so i must also thank councillors guthrie
field
and stringer from mit suffolk and
councillors beer
busby and jameson from baber
sometimes it took a while to arrive at a
position we could accept
but i don't feel alone in presenting
this plan to you
i'm doing it on behalf of that member
working group
my biggest thank you is reserved for rob
hobbs
our corporate manager for strategic
planning who is with us tonight to
answer any detailed questions you may
have
rob has been absolutely committed to
producing
for us an evidence-based plan of the
highest
quality and has carefully and
methodically put together the documents
you have before you today
it is a real achievement for rob and his
team
thank you rob
chairman i'm proposing the three
recommendations in
uh paper uh mc28
at paragraph three that is the approval
of the joint local plan pre-submission
document
authority to submit to the secretary of
state for an examination
and approval of the statement of
community involvement
thank you thank you councillor byrne
and do i have a second to please
yes councillor guthrie i will second
that thank you
councillor guthrie thank you okay we'll
now move to questions and debate
uh councillors excuse me sorry i reserve
the right to speak
thank you of course do you want to speak
now
no thank you i'll reserve the right okay
thank you thank you okay we'll now move
to questions and debates
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish however
they must be relevant to the subject
under discussion
and must be a question is that clear
must be a question
we'll save debate for debate when we get
to the depay
element counselors will only be allowed
to speak once
for three minutes and this will be timed
are there any questions please uh use
the hands up
facility
just going through the scroll bear with
me
i can see no handset for questions
everybody happy with that
chairman lots of hands
chief executive there's lots of hands in
the in the table if you can't see them
you'll be helpful if i indicate
for you um that would be useful i'm
starting to pick a couple up now i think
his connection issue i've only got two
hands up on my screen
so councillor otton please
uh thank you chairman um yes my question
is concerning neighborhood plans
where does this leave neighborhood plans
those already
awaiting the referenda and those in the
process of development
um in what sense where does it leave
them counselor alternate
um i don't quite follow because i i
don't think it leaves them in any
different place to to where they were
before
um we will continue um
uh support supporting them um
and uh
if they get through to their own
referendum stage they will start
together
gather weight if there is a discrepancy
between the
um between
them and the joint local plan in any way
perhaps um rob could answer that
question
but i i presume that's probably what you
what you were actually referring to is
it
that's correct
um okay well um chairman if i may
i will ask um rob hobbs to
uh give us his view on that and tell us
where neighborhood plans do sit
now yes please think it deserves it
thank you
okay sorry chair um yes so neighbour
plans will continue to be prepared
alongside the joint local plan um we're
publishing
um or seeking to approval to publish the
regulation 19 version
as the preferred options document this
this version sets out a
neighbor plan requirement minimum
requirement
and then the neighbor plan as long as it
meets the basic conditions of the plan
i.e
plans for that requirement then they can
bring forward um
sites um if they wish to do so now in
the case of
the joint local plan we've got a number
of neighbor plans being prepared
and um we've had to put forward in our
local plan sites that we consider a
deliverable
to meet the district-wide need now if a
neighbour plan
has an alternative view then they can
make a representation to the regulation
19 consultation
um detailing why they feel the sites
that we put forward um
you know we shouldn't be putting them
forward on what alternative state they
have
equally um like what happens with
neighbour plan examinations um during
the joint local planning examination
the inspector will may well consider
what neighborhood plans are currently
going through or as councillor bern said
have been
made i think we've got to recognize
there's always going to be an evolving
position
here and we'll try and work as best we
can with neighbour plan groups
um to where we're aware what they're
putting forward to guide them through
the process
thank you chairman that is reassuring
that
any neighborhood plans are still um
able to be revised if necessary thank
you
yeah very good question okay moving on
now councillor fleming please
yes um thank you thank you very much
chairman and thank you councillor byrne
i'd just like to take this opportunity
to echo councillor burns
recognition of the enormous amount of
hard work that has gone into
developing this plan by many people
some no longer with the council and some
here now
to see it through to the final stage so
um well done everyone we're almost there
with this important document
i just like to post a question on the
environment
because as as everyone knows
climate and biodiversity emergencies
have been declared
by our council and task force groups
have been developed
in response and actions have been
approved
by our cabinets the climate actions aim
to help us become
carbon neutral by 2030 and the
biodiversity actions are intended to
provide a blueprint
for reversing biodiversity loss and
achieving net gain
as recognized by um the government only
and
that's and i maybe i should be more
specific the natural capital committee
which is a cross-party working group
within the government only an
environmental net gain
approach in planning and development
will ensure that
aggregate natural capital is maintained
and enhanced
i i feel that's a really important
statement
this is a big ask and a big
responsibility
can you reassure me that the joint local
plan before us this evening
pushes as hard as it can to achieve
these aims
and can you tell me how these policies
can be strengthened and acted upon
through supplementary planning documents
that must be taken into account
when planning decisions are made
uh thank you council fleming um
yes indeed you can be assured that this
plan
in your in in your language pushes as
hard
as it can to achieve our environmental
ambitions it describes the environmental
issues on
pages 10 and 11 and in its vision on
page 13
describes how met suffolk will
transition to a low carbon future
with the ambition to be carbon neutral
by 2030
it describes how biodiversity will be
enhanced through the delivery
of measurable net gains across the
districts
supported by an identified ecological
network
on page 14 it describes how one of the
key objectives is to reduce
the drivers as climb of climate change
as much as possible from a social
economic and
environmental perspective again
emphasizing the ambition to become
neutral
by 2030
um ultimately the
main aims of the plan are to ensure
sustainable
development can be achieved whilst
protecting
and enhancing our natural built and
historic environment
this includes making effective use of
land
helping to improve diabetic biodiversity
using natural resources prudently
minimizing waste and pollution and
mitigating and
adapting to climate change
chapter 12 speaks for itself on
protection and management of the
environment the working group spent
considerable time
making sure the wording of strategic
policies sp9
on enhancing the environment and sp 10
on climate change were as strong as they
can be
within the framework that the national
planning policy framework
allows local policies
lp 17 provides for
environmental protection lp18 for
biodiversity net gain
and lp 19 describes how landscape
character assessments which are a part
of the plan's evidence base
have been carried out to guide decisions
about what development is appropriate in
the landscape
and provide a framework for the
provision of appropriate landscape
mitigation and then
enhancement the working group also spent
a lot of time getting
lp 25 on page 125
right this is the policy that really
manages approaches to sustainable
construction and design this might seem
like
too much detail for this meeting but it
is important
to really demonstrate the ambition
clause 3a
of the policy requires development to go
19
below the target emission rates for part
l of the building regs
3b requires the highest standards
possible
on water efficiency 3c requires
applicants to demonstrate climate change
adaptation
and mitigation measures and 3e
pushes at the use of onsite renewables
and 3f encourages materials with low
embodied energy
policies lp 27-29 cover energy sources
storage and distribution water resources
and flood risk so yes the plan
pushes as far as it can and yes
i've already spoken with officers about
starting work now
on supplementary planning documents
providing greater detail
on our expectations for biodiversity
open spaces and sustainable design so
that we can create them as quickly as
possible
once the plan has been adopted
thank you very much councillor bone that
is um that is reassuring that there was
some extra teeth there
to um add detail to those important
points thank you
thank you councillor thank you for your
detailed answer um just as we move
forward on these questions
we're all thankful for the team that's
put things together we'll summarize that
later
so please just come in straight with a
question and we'll now move on to
councillor mansell please
uh thank you chair um i'd just like to
ask if there's been any
uh consideration of extending the
minimum
six-week period for which
representations can be submitted
uh given that that six-week period is
due to start first thing
tomorrow morning and ends on christmas
eve
um whilst the country is in a bit of a
crisis
uh with a pandemic and this will
probably be in the lead up to the
strangest christmas ever
and i don't know that the joint local
plan will be the most important thing on
people's minds
and whether there's been any
consideration of extending that minimum
of six weeks
to enable as many people as possible to
put their representations forward thank
you councillor byrne please
um well may i may i bring in
um tom barker at this point to the
chairman
i'm pleased to as assistant director for
sustainable communities
i think he's the man to answer that one
uh yes thank you councillor burn um so
consideration has been given to this at
previous stages of the
consultations the council has always
gone beyond the
statutory period so in the first
consultation in 17
and the second consultation in 2019
this as councillor burn described in his
introduction is not a consultation in
the same way we publish the plan
and then invite representations from
people um
and i am very conscious that um it is
the lead up to christmas
and it is a strange situation for
everyone um given the the pandemic
however i think what we would normally
anticipate is
people tend to respond at the end of the
consultation period
um however long you make that so if it's
six weeks then they
they tend to answer at the end of the
six weeks if you made it eight they
would end it
at the end of the eight weeks and
extending it by a couple of weeks would
take it
through the christmas period and i think
there's no guarantee that that
necessarily
creates more space for people and we're
very conscious that there has been
significant pressure to
bring this plan forward um at
at pace and deliver it through as
quickly as possible conscious that
the the lack of a plan does impact on
planning decisions that are made on a
regular basis
um so therefore we've recommended six
weeks
um and judged that that is sufficient
for people to be able to make their
comments on soundness
um it ensures that we are minimizing the
risk of
moving beyond those kind of transitional
arrangements that the government have
described in their changes to the
current planning system and
provides ample time over a period of six
weeks for people to make their comments
conscious of course that there isn't
there isn't much
within the plan that should come as a
significant surprise
um the 2019 plan was detailed
and obviously amendments have been made
to that subject to
the consultation and taking into account
the consultation responses
but the six-week period is ample time
for
people to make their comments and for
parish councils and others to
convene emergency meetings conscious
that we
as i say that there has been significant
drive from from all
councillors to bring forward the plan as
quickly as possible
thank you thank you tom
thank you tom and hopefully that
answered the question councilmember
yeah it answers the question thank you
okay uh moving on then to councillor
passmore please
uh thank you chairman and david i want
to ask you this question but you may of
course wish to refer it to
tom or robert um one of the things that
i've always been very keen on going back
i think ever since i was first on this
council is
making sure we can do what we possibly
can to enable our
smaller villages to have some
development
um otherwise my fear has always been
that they will sense and die or just
become dormitory towns and so on
which i think will be very very
regrettable so the real
thrust of the question there are two
points to this do you believe that this
new um joint local plan will enable
those villages
more of these villages that wish to have
some development i'm not talking about
concreting everywhere over
to have some more housing if that's what
they want um
in order to help keep them more
sustainable more alive
get people moving in and out and i'm
particularly thinking of
social housing i'm also thinking of
first-time buyers
i think that's really really important
if we believe in a property owning
democracy which i certainly do
and then the other point if you go to
those who are approaching the sunset
of their life to coin a phrase will
there be provision in this or is there
provision in this plan to allow those
that can afford it
um to adapt their their homes for
example if they want to put annexes on
or change the layout or something
in order that they can re retain their
independence perhaps with help with
family and so on
so there's less burden on the services
that we have public services were very
hard pressed
so that we can keep people as i say
being independent and perhaps staying in
the villages or areas that they wanted
to live in
um so they do have a bit more of a
choice because at the moment
i'm not sure the way we are um situated
with policy we can do that terribly
effectively so it's
more about is it more of a cover all for
everywhere in mid-suffolk
um so that we can be a thriving
prosperous community particularly
looking at the housing mix and allowing
these villages which hitherto have had
very little option and for development
and in many cases
none whatsoever thank you counselor
um thank you councillor passmore um
i i will refer part of that question
certainly to
um either tom or rob
uh i i i do have
a little bit of something prepared
actually on the on the business of the
spatial distribution
um and i think it would ex
explain quite a bit if you allowed me to
um
to read that out chairman um i can
assure you however that there has been
very careful consideration for the
distribution
of development across our district
policy spo3
on page 33 of the plan identifies the
settlement hierarchy and the first limb
of that policy
details how the scale and location of
development
will depend upon the role of settlements
within the settlement hierarchy
the spatial distribution the capacity of
existing physical and social
infrastructure
or new stroke enhanced infrastructure as
well as having regard
to the natural built and historic
environment
the policy goes on to note that
settlements in the ipswich
fringe market towns and core villages
will act as a focus for development
policy sp04 on page 44
goes on to explain how the spatial
distribution
of housing set out in the plan seeks to
secure
a balance of growth in the strategic
transport
corridor areas as well as ensuring that
other market towns
and rural communities benefit from
appropriate development
as you can see from the tables on pages
40
on page 44 14 of development would go
towards settlements in the ipswich
fringe
31 to market towns and urban areas
38 to core villages which is biased
towards those on
transport corridors ten percent to
hinterland villages
and three percent to hamlets
on that latter point it's important to
note that this plan
does allow for small levels of
development in many
of our villages and hamlets policy ls01
on page 209 sets out a number of
allocations
in our hinterland villages and amulets
and along with policy lp01
on page 67 provides the mechanism to
open the door
to some low levels of development across
our rural villages
without opening it too widely
i hope that gives you uh and
and the other listeners or viewers
um uh some understanding about how the
plan
distributes development across the area
including the
the smaller villages and hamlets
um but i i will ask uh rob or
or tom whichever one would like to take
it first
um how to answer or if they will answer
your
question specifically that part of your
question which related to
um uh modification of houses for
uh people who are getting older and and
require changes and so on
who would like to take that one tom um
chair if it's okay i'll come in here um
thank you councillor bern
uh yes councillor passmore to reassure
you i guess to
to draw attention to policy lp02
which begins on page 69 that details the
approach that the plan will take to
residential annexes
and provide support where they are
appropriate for
annex provision for people that need
whether it's living carers or
or elderly relatives or those kind of
things where there is a dependency on
the main dwelling
so annexes are covered within lpo2
and in terms of housing mix lpo6
on page 77 details the approach to
housing mix and how the councils will
encourage
a mix that meets the requirements that
we've identified through the strategic
housing market assessment
so that that range of of smaller
dwellings
larger dwellings and a mix um that is
appropriate for
social housing um and lp06 is
that begins on page 77. so those are
your two key policies
and then there are other policies that
deal with extensions and other things
like that
perfect thank you very much
thank you and now moving on to
councillor
matthewson please thank you chair
um yeah can i ask i've got um a parish
and also a constituent who
each would like to um put
um put their case to the inspector
um at what point
should they be they should be actually
submitting
um something in writing to the inspector
or for the inspector perhaps okay i
think rob can
can answer this one um my understanding
is that it will be an online uh
representation
um not if i'm correct there rob
um and uh that in that online con
representation you uh are asked to tick
a box
if you wish to um attend
uh up the public inquiry when
uh when it reaches that particular point
of um
of the examination so that you could
if necessary put your point in person um
if that's correct if there's any more to
say rob would you would you like to
add to that as to how how people can
make specific representations like that
and
make their voice heard absolutely yeah
on our website we'll have um details of
how to make a representation during the
six-week period
um it does have a strict um closing
point
but um as long as the representation is
made and it's made appropriately
then that representation will go on to
the inspector and as councillor berna
leads to there will be a box that ticks
to say whether you wish to appear at a
hearing or not as well
that will be within within the six week
period starting tomorrow
to make the representation absolutely
and then the examination would start
once the plan has been submitted to the
secretary of state
thank you perfect thank you
moving on then to councillor pratt
please
yes thank you and i'd just like to thank
um councillor byrne for
um for highlighting um where the
um policy for biodiversity net gain had
been
sharpened um i do i do have a a quick
question
um with regards to lpa 18 it says
that we will identify and pursue
opportunities for secure diversity net
gain
whereas in sp09 it says all development
proposals will be required
to enhance and protect biodiversity net
gain
um i'm just wondering which is it are we
are we
supporting proposals that wish to
secure biodiversity net gain or will it
absolutely be a requirement for every
single development
council burn please um
i'm just trying to turn up those
particular policy numbers
have you got them there tom
rob
either of you um yes so the local policy
is policy
lp18 and that's on page
108 and the strategic policy i think is
sp09 but let me just check
um yes spo 9 deals with enhancement and
management of the environment
and that's on page 63.
okay so um
you've identified a just
an inconsistency between those two
policies
uh council prep um
well well potentially yes i just want to
i just want to know whether um all
new developments will be required to
meet the biodiversity net gain
policy
rob would you like to come in on that
please say chair if i could come in on
that
um yeah i mean biodiversity net gain is
something that the policies will seek to
achieve
i think what needs to be able to be more
in mind is some some developments um
if they're particularly small um may not
necessarily be able to um
do the biodiversity they're going on the
site in particular but certainly they'd
need to then identify how they could do
that
so that's something that we will seek to
achieve 10 biodiversity net gains
across the district as a whole looking
at it from a strategic approach
okay so it will be context specific
depending on size
and also uh the schemes will need to um
identify how they can contribute to that
biodiversity net gain
okay okay thank you
thank you um so now we have counselor
well in place
thank you chair um could somebody please
explain why an application for a site
not shown as an allocation
in an adopted neighborhood plan and not
shown as an
allocation in this joint local plan
should be permitted
this is the case for a number of sites
across the district including one in
stowe upland
i believe it to be true that officers
and some members
of the planning referrals committee knew
that the stone upland site had been
removed
from the allocations map how could it be
that
permission should be recommended and
agreed
recommended by officers and agreed by
committee for the development
but now we now we have this draft local
plan
what what advice can you give to members
having to explain this sort of situation
to residents
and also if there are objections to the
removal of these sites
at this stage perhaps from the the
applicant or
a previous uh previous owner or whatever
what defense can be offered at the
examination
by the at the examination offered by our
witnesses
to the independent inspector
castle burn please if you can yeah yeah
that's um
i mean you're you're you're actually
chilling on ground which is
i think not relevant to this particular
uh the context in which in which you're
asking that question
um that is something that would
would have to be presented as a as a
separate representation in the way we've
just been talking about
as a specific a challenge to the uh
to the plan um if if you think
that's a a challenge to its soundness or
its legality in any way that that would
be the
um that would be the way in which to
present that challenge
uh and it would be up to the inspector
to
um either uphold the the present
position or to make
recommendations for amending the present
position in some way
but again uh as i say that is that is
probably a legal consideration which is
outside the scope of this particular
particular meeting but um tom would you
like to
confirm or modify that and
before we go any further so i think the
first element of the question is
probably not relative to what we're
actually discussing tonight in fairness
and actually some of this can be brought
up at the consultation stage but over
two tom please
um thank you councillor humphreys um i
think
those parts of the question and it was
kind of multi-limbed so
so please excuse me if i if i missed any
parts of it
um but absolutely some parts of the
question referred to
active decision taking by planning
committee which isn't the
subject of this item but if i pick up
the point around
i think what you were asking was around
the weight
that is attached to the plan as it
emerges through the process
um so subject to counsellors agreeing
this plan tonight it will go out for
consultation
and at that stage it continues to have
limited weight in decision taking
as the evidence that underpins it starts
to get tested as it moves into
examination
and the different different
parties put forward various different
arguments and and kind of
go through that test and challenge
process then the plan gains
further weight and will become a more
important consideration in decision
taking
and then at the point at which the
inspector
goes through the examination and makes
their judgment
and it comes back for the council to
adopt at that stage then it would have
full weight and it would be
the development plan essentially so it's
a it's a process of of
steadily gaining weight for decision
taking purposes
as the evidence that underpins it
starts to be tested and challenged
chair if i didn't answer the the thrust
of the question which was
uh around my concern um
that it would be difficult to defend the
removal of the sites
a site that was was in the
july 19 july 19 allocations map it's not
in the
the most recent allocations map it's
gained planning permission
how can you what arguments can you put
against the view of um a developer who
um has gained that permission um and
you're now
saying yeah but it's not in the
allocations map
how can you how can you maintain the
position that it should not be in the
allocations map
if i may um i think along with um
tom this is outside of the scope of what
we're actually meant to be asking
questions
on on the joint local plan as we go
forward the consultation phase and
examination examination
so i think you you are bordering
on a planning issue here rather than
what we're actually here to debate and
discuss
uh tom correct me if i'm wrong um no
counselor humphreys i think you're
absolutely correct but i'm
more than happy to um address this
question with councillor welum
yeah we'll do that outside of the
meeting and please from development
management yeah
please do um thank you it's not the
place for it so councillor welling
please contact tom and discuss it
offline thank you
okay moving on then we'll have a
question now from uh
councillor field
no i don't have a question
okay you put your hands down no problem
uh then let's move on to
uh counselor richardson please
uh thank you very much chair and if
counselor burn agrees i wanted to just
ask
a quick point of uh clarification based
on something that rob
hobbs said um in answer to councillor
orton's question
um if i have the sequencing of events
right
obviously we published um our preferred
options document last year
issued a consultation based on on that
document
and then obviously we've then published
the most recent document in the last
couple of weeks
but if i can just ask has there been any
engagement with
parish councils and neighborhood
planning teams
um between the publication of those two
documents
um to incorporate because i'm conscious
of the fact that the current document
contains some changes um which weren't
consulted on last year so what
i've effectively had just like a bit of
clarification on what efforts have been
made to engage with
parish councils and neighborhood
planning teams about some of those
changes
thank you chair thank you councillor ben
um okay well thank you uh there there
was as i
i think i've already explained a
cross-party
um cross-council working group
uh that considered uh the suggested
changes or um
yeah the suggest suggested changes to
uh to to the plan these were brought by
officers to a working group meeting and
uh
views were expressed as to how those
changes should be um accommodated or not
uh within the plan now it was on the
basis
one presumes as as our members are
um there to represent their constituents
uh that that some of the constituent
considerations
and the uh parish council considerations
will have been brought to the meeting
via the um
the district councillors themselves um
outside of those meetings i would need
to refer back to
um robert hobbs in order to
answer the question directly harry uh
sorry council richardson so um
can't may i do that please chairman uh
ask rob to
comment this please which to which
parish councils
were involved or communicated with
during the course of the modifications
amendments
yes so so where um when they were
planning groups to be preparing
neighborhood plans
and they've shared with us their um
their neighbor plans as they've been
evolving
then obviously we've been aware of them
what um groups are coming forward with
and we're able to
to engage in communication with them i'm
conscious there's a number of
neighborhood plans being prepared
and some of them um take some
considerable time to prepare and so we
we're not always aware of what's going
on if if a neighbour plan
group hasn't um shared something with us
so
where where um labour plan group is
preparing a plan and they've engaged in
dialogue with us and then absolutely
we've we've taken that into
consideration
thank you does that answer the question
yes thank you chair
thank you uh moving on uh the only other
person i've got now is council um
amaro morrison
thank you very much jeff i'm a roasting
i'm sorry my apologies
emphasis on the row yeah i understand
it's a long one
um so um we've
we've heard how the jlp stipulates
for certain environmental concerns
at the planning stage
it's also known that how the built
environment can impact
inhabitants psychologically so
can my colleague highlight how
the jlp might stipulate certain criteria
that will promote community cohesion and
well-being thank you councillor bern
sorry can can would you say the last
little bit please
again council ameros sure sure
um can my colleague highlight how the
jlp
stipulates criteria that will promote
community
cohesion and well-being
thank you and i'm your colleague yep in
that context
i hope so yeah
well um as uh
tom barker is the assistant director for
sustainable communities which covers
both communities community cohesion um
and planning um i really do think that
although i may be your colleague i'm not
the man to
answer that question as as certainly not
as well as he could
so tom may i hand that to you please
um absolutely counsellor um and um
yes this is a subject very close to my
heart um
and i think if you're looking for
specifics um probably
lp 30 which details um open space
provision
lp 26 which looks at design and amenity
and lp 31 which looks at services and
facilities within the community
each of those local policies seeks to
ensure that the built environment is
optimizing its contribution towards the
well-being of our communities and the
the individuals within them the planning
system obviously is
is one factor that plays into all of
those things
and the the way that we go about
decision taking this is actually an area
where i'd really like to see us
developing supplementary planning
documents and i've had
conversations with the clinical
commissioning group and um
and others on the way that we can look
at that the way that we can draw in
health impact assessments for example on
our
major or significant schemes um
and the way that we can draw our
colleagues from within the health system
into consultations on planning
applications so that we can bring their
experience and kind of professional
specialism
to bear on this and also within our own
organization as we develop
our well-being strategy a key part of
that will be
developing the evidence base that
underpins it and then using that
evidence
to inform planning consultations on
individual applications
so that we can ensure that we're doing
the kind of the
whole range of things that that maximize
the benefit that development can bring
to people's well-being
some of that is in design and aesthetics
i'm in danger of running away with
myself here sorry because then
as i say you've asked the question very
close to my heart so i'll try and keep
it limited
um but absolutely there are a number of
things and i'd be more than happy to
spend some time with you outside of the
meeting taking you through the range of
different ways
that planning can as i say maximize the
contribution
to well-being and the creation of happy
places
and bring our planners to the place
where at pre-application
discussions they ask the architect how
is this application going to bring joy
to this place and see the slight look of
confusion on the architect's face and
and and take it from there i'm really
glad to hear that kind of passion from
from yourself and i welcome yeah those
aspirations of bringing forward
supplementary uh
plans and yeah i want to support you in
that any way i can
thank you yeah very good answer thank
you and uh moving on now to council of
war boys uh before we do uh if you've
asked your question and you have no
further questions can you please lower
your hands
thank you
councillor boys you there
there yeah we've got you your question
please
yeah um i enjoyed uh
council fleming's question and and
council burns detailed response and
that this proposed joint local plant
has now got teeth with regard to
biodiversity and
carb and achieving carbon neutrality so
the question is would it be fair then
for
me to assume that as technologies are
changing very rapidly and also
guidance and um best practice with
regard to
biodiversity that in
development committees we could actually
rely
on the policies in this joint local plan
to
um
encourage developers to to put forward
the best possible
um solutions with regard to energy use
and
environmental changes
um thank you council warboys uh
they're probably two answers to that
quick question because there were two
parts to the question
um energy use and environmental issues
uh could could well be dealt with in
slightly different ways
for example the supplementary planning
document
that is being proposed for
the biodiversity elements of
uh and environmental protection
uh objectives um
that would be that would be contain the
policy and the teeth that you would need
in in your planning committees to
to insist on on biodiversity net gain
etc on the
energy issues um
probably i would ask rob there
to help me out a little bit with the um
with the extent to which we can
rely on on the plan uh because there's a
the
there's a limit to the to the extent
that the policies can push
uh in the in that respect i think um but
but he'll be able to enlighten you
better than i can
rob would you mind expanding
yeah so the policies um in the plan
effectively provide the framework
um to guide future development and as
you as councilor burns alluded to
supplementary planning documents um they
can't set policy but they can
add more detail around um guiding those
developments and
our material consideration to to
planning decisions some racial planning
documents can also be reviewed
fairly frequently to keep up to date
with technology
local plans tend to be reviewed every
well they are reviewed every five years
that's the requirement
so um we feel that the journal plan
provides that flexible policy framework
and then absolutely recognize that over
time technologies will move quickly and
and
that's where um like i say having the
appropriate guidance in place can then
make sure that those technologies are
taken advantage of
thank you thank you both thank you and
we have a final question i think which
is councilman matthewson please
yes very quick one a lot of emphasis is
being put onto this
um supplementary planning guidance which
is very welcome
could we have a timetable on that um
maybe
subsequent to this meeting in in the
form of a paper to
the next council or or somewhere thank
you
um well so certainly i'll give that
um a consideration council matheson
uh the the intention as you probably as
you heard when i introduced this
um i've already um opened
a discussion on the subject with with
officers
and um when we when we get uh
officers do have a fair bit of work to
do um
during the course of the next uh next
six weeks
and um probably for a month or two
after that we're dealing with the
representations collating them getting
them into order putting them in a fit
state
to pass on to the inspector
um but almost as soon as we've managed
to get the
uh joint local plan in its present form
um
off our desks as it were then work will
will begin on the supplementary planning
documents that are going to
add to its value
and um i i will i will see about uh
bringing a progress report to subsequent
council meetings yeah
thank you hopefully that answered the
question so we're now going to move on
to debate
um again you'll have three minutes which
will be timed
each counsellor can speak we'll do this
with the hands up
method again in order but we're having a
few technological issues this end we've
seen hands up so just give us a couple
of minutes
while we count hands and then we'll
start debate
molly
okay we can start so we'll start the
debate with councillor morley please
thank you chair this plan has been a
long time in the making
but it is a comprehensive new plan
replacing all existing documents
including
the old local plan from 1998 the core
strategy from 2007
and 2012 and and also the stone market
area action plan
it provides us with the strong new
policies and detailed allocations giving
more clarity to our communities than at
any time since i became a councillor
the evidence base that under underpins
the plan
is more detailed than we've ever
produced before and we've made huge
efforts to involve our communities
we started gathering new evidence in
2016
and consulted on the main issues and
options in 2017
giving communities longer to respond
than the regulations require
we then gathered more evidence and
alongside huge amounts of work from
officers
the member working group refined the
plan based on the thousands of comments
we received
we then consulted the public on our
preferred approach in 2019
again giving people much longer to
respond than the regulations require
the cross-party member working group
continued to meet and decide how best to
take comments into account
and respond to what the evidence base
was telling us
and we haven't stopped despite the
disruptive impact of this pandemic
more evidence has been provided the
options have been further refined
and have been assessed for their
sustainability and financial viability
there will always be compromises and
parts of the plan that are not to
everyone's liking
but i am confident that we have the best
plan possible and one that will put us
in a strong position to address climate
change
strengthen biodiversity and protect our
natural and historic environment
while at the same time helping us to
grow the economy and provide the homes
our residents need
this plan will help us to build great
communities with bright and healthy
futures
that everyone is proud to call home and
i am proud to support it
i would also like to thank council byrne
for taking on this portfolio last may
and carrying on where his predecessors
left off
this is a portfolio that has
considerable public scrutiny
and it has been enhanced by council
byrne's personal passion
as an environmentalist and i also want
to thank
our cross-party working group of
councillors guthrie field and stringer
for their involvement in this
significant piece of work
and the rest of the mid-suffolk cabinet
for all their support and passion to
ensure we get to this regulation stage
i also want to thank our friends in
baber councillors beer busby and jameson
led by portfolio holder councillor arty
and supported all the way by the baber
leader council award
and the rest of the baba cabinet and
finally i want to thank our officers led
by
chief exec arthur chavonia assistant
director tom barker
and the strategic planning team with
robert hobbs
their persistence and commitment to
making this happen
is a great example of our agile
workforce
thank you thank you councillor molly
excellent timing uh now moving on to
councillor stringer please
three minutes thank you chair
uh as ever i started with the speech and
end up completely rewriting it and
throwing in the bin
mostly because of this morning's
activity uh i had the pleasure of
serving on a planning
development control committee meeting
this morning uh
with councillor passmore and the last
time we did that was in 2009
uh and i think either chairing it was
either councillor gemmill melvin or
frost uh and we were operating under the
1998 local plan
and what was drilled into us at those
meetings was what you really need to
give the public and the developer was
certainty
well since then i think certainty is
something
that that really hasn't been involved
with with planning and certainty
seems to have sort of drifted away much
because of the the plans that we had
then that gave that certainty
have been brought into question and been
ruled out of date
so it's imperative that we actually get
a plan
that's workable has teeth and is deemed
out of date even by governments that
seem to change their mind every
fortnight
i think in the years that we've had a
challengeable five-year land supply
i think my own personal views we've seen
what's looked like to many
utter chaos with what's been going on
and there hasn't seemed to be a
plan uh and that's certainly what we
need
so i was delighted to be part of the
working group uh that looked into the
new
joint local plan uh at times
uh you know if you're looking at tv
series those meetings didn't resemble
the tv series like borgen
it more sort of represented it's a
knockout but we'll leave the planning
inspector to work out who's playing a
joker card
we will but during those we really did
try and i certainly did on behalf of my
group
trying to get their aspirations into
trying to temper this plan
into something that could be sustainable
in the eyes of our communities
and i have to say i failed for some of
you
and i apologize i did argue your points
uh to try and make this as sustainable a
plan as possible
so i think everyone that will be voting
tonight
should be voting uh you know to look at
whether you know that we do need a
robust plan
but i would completely understand if
some of you cannot support this plan at
the moment
because you're being offered two
versions of chaos
uh you you are you are being told if you
don't vote for this plan
then you know all sorts of chaos is
going to rain down upon you
yet for some of you that chaos is
already at your door
so i would completely understand if some
members can't support this plan
i will be supporting this plan uh i
won't be hugely flag waving about it
because
there's elements of the plan i'm
incredibly proud about there's elements
that i really feel like
i've not i've not succeeded in what i
was set out to do
but i hope we do agree the plan tonight
because i think we need to
to get this plan out there and let the
inspector work out what's what
uh thank you chair thank you councillor
stringer and
thank you for the work on the cross
party
members working group it's appreciated
and as councillor morley said
we don't always get our own way and
there's been compromises from all sides
to develop what we've got in front of us
so well done everybody let's move on now
to
councillor flatman please
thank you chair just carrying on from
what um councillor passmore had to say
earlier
i was very pleased to see that hamlets
and clusters on the outskirts of
villages
have not been forgotten some small-scale
development
have will be really welcomed
of the right design to make sure
communities grow and thrive and support
neighbouring villages
that may have might have businesses and
facilities
leading to sustainable sustainable
healthy and vibrant communities
creating homes that are needed and
desired
many of which would be built out by
small builders and self
builds
many of which their designs and specs
are far far superior than larger
developers
we often hear the quote the right homes
in the right places
it will be it will be
advantageous to all to have the plan the
jpl
the jlp rather to back us
so that we get the design we want
with with that will meet our needs
and our standards thank you chair
thank you council flatman and moving on
to councillor gold please
thank you very much uh uh chan
um i i wanted to start by quoting or
rather paraphrasing uh councillor carter
we were sat together not long after we
were elected uh considering yet another
application where there were no clear
planning reasons for
uh refusal and council carter recently
questioned
where's our democratic role and the the
absence of an up-to-date uh local plan
has impacted enormously on our
democratic role we are
in too many cases uh severely limited in
our ability to deal with applications
because policies are out of date and we
hear those dreaded words
the tilted balance is being engaged
we have the opportunity and green the
plan before us
to regain something of our democratic
role the plan
brings together evidenced and
deliverable policies
to which we've all had an extensive
opportunity
to to contribute and which will shape
the future of our district
in the ways that we can determine
of course there are many given factors
that we have to accommodate
not least challenging targets for
housing growth
and it's not the task of the local plan
to challenge those nationally
determined targets but to find a way in
which they can be met
as part of a positive and coherent
vision of the future of our district
the plan represents an enormous
achievement on the part of the
of the council not least the officers
who've accomplished
the most demanding and complex tasks so
let's agree the repo the plan and and
tilt the balance back in our democratic
favor
thanks very much thank you some good
points
uh councillor otton please
the problem with this of course is that
um when you have governments
that insist on having a standard plan
for the whole country
this leaves areas devoid of housing
and devoid of housing need and yet
in results in overheating in areas of
the southeast
um the problem we need to have is that
we need to treat
people differently and we need to have a
definition of key workers and we need to
make sure
that we prevent neighbouring towns and
villages
from merging into one another
um the whole object of the plan
must be to assist in safeguard
safeguarding the countryside
and any anlbs and to rule out
development
major development in those areas we need
to preserve the settings and special
character of historic towns and villages
and we need to use article 4 direction
to avoid a negative impact on our
communities
um i would just like to take an issue
with a
statement that councillor passmore made
um he seems to imply that we're only
wanting to provide homes for home
ownership
and i believe that that is not correct
we need to be providing homes
for people under any circumstances
whether these are to rent
to buy and in any other circumstances
that they find themselves in
um so i hope that and i'm sure that this
plan
will make sure
uh councillor and we seem to have lost
you are you still there
okay um some good points um moving on
then counselor geek please
thank you chair um i would like to
explain why i don't support this joint
local plan
despite the hard work that's clearly
been put into it and the problems that
will no doubt ensue if we have no local
plan in place
firstly although there have been
improvements since earlier drafts it is
still
incredibly unfair to the villages around
where i live
at the western end of the a14 the
villages of thurston woolpit and
elmswell they all have more housing
allocated than the
towns of needham market and i first and
alone has more housing allocated than
both of these towns combined
secondly there are some unfortunate
aspects to the plan that are clearly not
reasonable for example the suggestion
that a third of elmsville's children
should go to school in woolpit
this is purely based on office of land
from developers it's not based on any
kind of sensible plan
but my main concern is that this plan
stipulates that for every single new
resident of mid-suffolk we have to build
nearly one and a half houses
that's per resident not per household
this over supply is intended to bring
the price down
but of course as the lecturing review
says house builders won't do this
as it's not in their interests to bring
prices down and we have no powers to
make them
in addition all these houses can have
gas boilers all of them can be made from
bricks with an enormous carbon footprint
rather than our traditional east anglian
carbon capture material of wood
and none of them have to be to net zero
carbon standards
so this vast number of new homes is
utterly unsustainable in the real sense
of the word
it may be sustainable in the
government's definition of the word but
that's just a fantasy of newspeak it
bears no relationship to what the word
means to ordinary people
it has been recently estimated that at
current rates with plans like these
we will not achieve net zero carbon in
housing for another 700 years
and yet the government keeps on saying
that we must build build build
so the central problem is that current
planning law is utterly unsustainable in
the real world
yet we as a planning authority can do
nothing about it
the government has constantly watered
down the power of the planning system
and now the mppf has completely
undermined it so if we
keep waving through plans like this
simply because the government will
impose something even more appalling on
us
we're complicit in degrading our local
and our global environment
and i can see that there's nothing we
can do about it given current government
policy
but this doesn't mean that i should vote
for it to go forward i'm afraid
thank you councillor geek uh councillor
otton is now back with us um you've
still got 45 seconds remaining if you'd
like to finish off please counselor
um um i just lost connections so i'm not
quite sure where i got to
we've got 45 seconds to talk about
anything you wish i
i think i have made my point did you
hear what i said about councillor
passmore
yes we did and uh i might give him a
right to reply when it gets to him
because he is going to speak
shortly okay thank you thank you um so
moving on then we'll go to
councillor mansell please
uh thank you chair um um i'd just like
to
um maybe maybe following councillor geek
isn't the best plan for me because we're
both
from the same local area uh this new
local plan has certainly been a long
time coming and there is no doubt that
we do need an
up-to-date local plan however just
because we need one
does not necessarily mean we should be
satisfied with this particular
local plan i'm no in no way demeaning
the work that all our officers have been
doing
nor the members on the joint working
group and i am very pleased with some of
the new policies which incorporate
sustainable design and mitigation
against climate change
however my concerns are with the spatial
distribution which underpins
all these promising new local policies
there are fundamental flaws in that
spatial distribution which cannot be
mitigated
by all the development management
policies and supplementary planning
guidance in the world
nor by a review which will occur almost
as soon as this plan becomes policy
i'm not going to discuss the issues with
the overall numbers that's already been
done for me by my colleague
i'm really going to comment on the
distribution of the housing not as
quantity
along our main transport corridor the
a14
surely we should be able to engineer
that the development is co-located
with the infrastructure needed to enable
the development but no
we are being developer-led maybe due to
funding considerations which are way
outside of our control
so if a developer says hey if you let me
build a load of houses here
i'll offer you some land for a new
school even if that school is in the
wrong place
that is not in my mind plan led planning
if the infrastructure needed to enable
development is not in the right place
then that development is not
sustainable in other words if you want
to put a load of new housing
in a large key service centre then you
need to be able to provide the
educational facilities
within that key service centre not in a
neighboring key service centre
we need to be doing all that we can to
enable more people to make the correct
choice of transport options certainly if
we were to
meet at carbon zero by 2030
for all too long we as a country not
necessarily just we as a district
council
have been enabling a car-centric society
we need to start to make it easier for
people to walk and cycle to amenities
rather than jump in a car so that they
can make that right choice
this plan does not do this i'm not
arguing that we shouldn't accept the
level of development
it's just that it's in the wrong place
so unfortunately
all those lovely policies do not
outweigh the fundamental flaw that i see
in the spatial distribution so it is
with great regret that i'm not able to
support this joint local plan
yeah some well put points actually let's
move on now to
councillor mayor please
thanks chair um i'll be a sixth sense as
i can
um i think this is an excellent document
um i've
the more i look at it the more i'm
impressed with the the detail and the
amount of work that's gone into it so
i offer my congratulations to the cross
party team and also the council officers
have brought it
for us tonight although i think it's a
strong document
i don't contend that it's perfect indeed
some settlements have been asked to
absorb
more housing than they would wish and i
have one
interland village that's been asked to
accept 10 of the total number of houses
required for all hinterland villages in
mid-suffolk
and that's with no doctor surgery and
little more than one shot
but i don't think these individual
issues undermine or invalidate the whole
plan
i also accept that the plan does not
offer a complete solution
more detail is required indeed the
sustainability assessment rightly
identifies
that whilst a plan delivers positive
benefits in all areas assessed
minor negative impacts were also
identified
delivery of the plan is undoubtedly a
challenge particularly with regard to
environmental issues and we should not
pretend the joint local plan contains
all the guidance and control measures
that are required
but again this doesn't undermine
undermine or validate the plan
the joint local plan offices a offers us
supplementary planning documents and
these i see is the real teeth
these could deliver the biodiversity
the active transport and help us attack
climate change
but the important point to note is that
without a joint local plan
you have no supplementary planning
documents
your teeth are removed and you're
sitting there as a gumless or
a gum driven an organization
with just gums trying to attack the
problems
joint opera plan is not the complete
answer but it does provide a robust
vehicle that will allow us to develop
the solution
over the next 16 years if we prevent the
joint local plan from moving to the next
stage in its development
we will be denying ourselves the tools
we need to meet the massive challenges
we face
if this were to happen our residents
could quite justifiably accuse us
of fiddling while roam burns i believe
the joint local plan is fit for purpose
and i support the motion thank you
thank you moving on to councillor
uh brewster please
thank you chair um yeah my start on this
will sound rather like our leader but uh
this joint local plan has been a long
time in the making
quite understandably given the various
changes the government
has contributed to planning and the
subsequent modifications which had to be
made
our offices in cross-party working group
have worked very hard to achieve this
excellent plan
and i dread to think of the number of
hour officer hours which have been spent
on on making it
we now have a draft local plan which is
ready to meet
the pre-submission regulation 19 stage
from an economic angle an economic
growth angle
i believe this plan is much needed as we
move on into the future
yes it will provide new homes in the
right places
it will grow the economy of
mid-southwark by providing
not just homes but also employment to
match those homes
we will see the economic benefits of
tourism growing
and will witness our town centers
growing in ways
we might never have suspected and all
this
in a sustainable way with the
appropriate infrastructure
i mentioned employment and we are facing
a time with possible
considerable unemployment due to the
pandemic
we will need this growth in our economy
to ensure that we can grow
our schools skill space and offer future
employment
to our young and the older in the
community
individually we might not agree with
everything that's in the plan
or what is proposed in our awards but i
believe that as members of this council
we all have a duty to approve tonight
the rem
recommendations for this joint local
plan to go forward
to its next phase thank you chair
thank you and now moving on to
councillor heading in police
thank you um i just want to say um um
thanks to robert and tom
and all the hard work they've done so
far and everyone
gary did um barry did say he didn't want
that but i really appreciate all the
hard work they've done and robert
answering questions at the weekends and
i've emailed him i really
like that was you know great there's
already been extensive
consultation on our parishes um you know
as well as our statutory bodies getting
to this point with almost 20 000
responses collated and documented
as a result of several years detailed
work when i first done
saw the plan over three years ago i was
horrified to find that fretting field
was considered a core village
along with the likes of thurston woolpit
debenham stradbuck
and the evidence used to determine that
criteria seemed at least 20 years out of
date when there'd been a butcher's a
post office a bakery and several other
shops and services
available there i'm pleased to say by
2019 along with many other villages it
had been reclassified as a hinterland
village not everyone will get what they
or their parishes want
but the issue but the issues caused by
us not having up-to-date local plan are
extensive
causing frustration and misunderstanding
by counsellors applicants and developers
alike
and quite frankly resulting in
inappropriate development across the
district
anyone who sits on our planning
committees as i have done five years
will be aware of the decisions they make
with regard to how much weight they give
to various guiding documents
having a fully compliant adopted plan
removes that uncertainty
he must move forward and approve this
plan because anything else is a
retrograde step
the rest of the world will not stop so
the net result is our villages will
become less sustainable
losing local facilities such as pubs
schools and community hubs
we can debate the actual numbers until
we're blue in the face but the fact is
the numbers are not defined by us
all we can do is respond with where and
how we are to meet those numbers
and i want to take issue with um penny
saying this was like a
a national plan this is not this is our
plan written by our people
and um anyway i'm all for it good work
people
thank you thank you and moving on to
councillor ekpanyong please
thank you chairman and pretty much
since i've been a counselor we've talked
about the jlp
and i take my hat off to everyone who's
worked very hard to create this plan
as has been alluded to it's a plan a bit
like a forecast it's not perfect
but we need a plan it's a plan that
charts the path forward
for our ambitious for for our ambitions
for sustainable economic growth and the
prosperity of our residents now and into
the future
the plan has been long in the making and
has received support through many
previous council meetings during its
creation and is backed has been
said by an enormous body of evidence
so for me it would be very perverse and
somewhat imprudent if we were not to
take this forward to the next stage as
recommended
so i will be voting for it to be so
taken and i would encourage all of my
fellow counselors to do the same
as we all have a responsibility to our
residents to have a local plan
thank you
thank you very much and moving on now to
councillor hicks please
thank you very much mr chairman um well
before us today
is a draft joint local plan which
clearly has taken a great deal of time
to be completed
and in fact i think it was back in june
2016
when we as an authority approved the
start of the work and we set off on a
very very long journey that has taken
many stages to get to today and of
course
most importantly this has included
liaising with our residents
throughout this long journey i am sure
in this virtual chamber that we're in
tonight we can all give examples of what
happens when a local planner is out of
date and
i can sitting on development control
committee at times get frustrated
so it is a welcome step that this is
moving forward
the allocation of sites of course is
never easy
um and i do welcome the fact that this
authority has worked
closely with our communities to deliver
in clearly a planned and a transparent
way
and i also would like to thank officers
for the work that has been undertaken
over many many years actually to reach
to today's stage i do think it is vital
tonight we take a strategic view
as we are all as we are only too well
aware of the importance of the local
plan
we all will have individual examples no
doubt in which we feel things maybe are
not
exactly as we wish but that's not
surprising
the scale of work that has taken place
and there will be an opportunity to give
to take part in the technical
consultation
of course over the next few weeks and to
share any outstanding concerns
and the inspector of course can look at
and give an independent view
i do think it's important we recognize
that the evidence base
supporting the draft jlp has continued
to develop and has not actually just
stood still
the settlement hierarchy and the key
services
the role of key services and facilities
of course have played a vital role
and evidence in terms of flood risk
heritage landscape transport
water sustainability habitats
infrastructure delivery just to name a
few also playing their part
and i'm also delighted to see that
enhancing and managing the environment
and the networks of green infrastructure
are again
in place and will come forward with
supplementary documents
so mr chairman i welcome what is before
us the planning framework is vital
to guide the development and to
facilitate the growth in mid suffolk
over the next 25 years
and i am disappointed in councillor geek
and mansell
and to me the logic defies logic um
with no local plan in place you're
creating an
effect of free for all and i'm
disappointed you'll be voting for a free
for all in planning
it is vital to our residents that we
move forward and we have
certainty with the right sites in the
right locations
and i thank the working party and the
officers for the excellent work
and will be supporting the
recommendation thank you
thank you councillor hicks and that was
an important point actually that we can
still be involved in the technical
consultation
that's a point we shouldn't forget so
moving on now we'll go to
councillor turner please
um i'm these are my reasons for not
supporting
the local plan my main concerns being
raised by parishioners
is the lack of consultation that then
name for example in the village of beta
and a land allocation emerged in the
joint local plan just last week
and no one on the parish council or the
neighborhood plan were aware of it till
then
uh the neighborhood plan team and the
parish council have been working with
villagers and landowners to deliver more
houses than district council requires in
more suitable locations
and to include affordable housing now
that work may all be wasted
if the local plan is approved tonight
the bait and emerging neighborhood plan
cannot be examined until this
till the site issue is resolved
okay so did you get as far as if the
local plan is approved tonight
yes it's so if the local players prove
tonight the bait
until the site issue is resolved
otherwise the neighborhood plan would
not be in conformity
with the local plan and would therefore
parish councils have spent a lot of time
and public money put into
together officers seem to be consulting
more with land developers than with
parish councils
and feel their efforts have been wasted
thank you
because thank you yeah there's a bit of
a disrupted um
audio on that but i think we got the
gist of what you're trying to say thank
you
um so now we're going to move on to uh
counselor passmore and before you start
your three minutes i will give you a
chance
uh for a point of explanation to
counselor otton if you feel you need to
please
yeah thank you very much sir chairman
yes i did want to um address penny's
point
um maybe i didn't make it clear enough
when i said i believed in the property
only democracy that certainly did not
mean
i did not approve of building affordable
homes homes to rent
public sector housing shared equity and
i've always been in favor of that
um so i wouldn't like anybody at this
meeting or anybody listening to the
public to think i was against that
because that definitely is not the case
and that has been the case ever since i
was a cancer
going back almost as long as you penny
but not quite
um so i just wanted to set that right
that that's not the case
uh i do support a balance mixed housing
but i do believe that we want to give
people the opportunity like many of us
here
own our own homes we need to do what we
can to try and help other people
aspire to that um that that ownership so
that's that
okay so that's that first bit chairman
and i hope i won't take three minutes
for the next bit so thank you for
indulgence
um i don't want to repeat what everybody
else has said but
having lived in suffolk for most of my
life and suffered for all of my life so
far
it's always been the case you know that
i think mid-suffolk has always embraced
change and has always tried to do it
sensitively and trying to balance the
competing demands
in what is a or certainly until very
recently because of the pandemic
a high growth area i think it has done
an admirable job
but of course if we are to progress and
preserve our heritage
the really really rich mosaic of our
villages towns market towns
hamlets and small settlements we do need
this framework and i think this does an
excellent job in providing that so i
shall certainly be
supporting voting for this district plan
and just remind everybody this is at a
strategic level it's not really for
discussing
individual ward cases as my colleague
john whitehead will know in clayton and
barham
we do have some very big proposed
developments here but that is not this
is not the time
to discuss that it provides that high
level framework for the next
um many many years that was until 2037
so
very important we do that and it does
balance the need for economic
development and housing and opportunity
for all
i'm really pleased with the uh with the
biodiversity
agenda and so on and please remember
everybody i hope you can support this
because there is an opportunity to give
further input
and also the work there for
supplementary planning documents
and if anybody likes to know it i'm very
keen on swallows and what about some
swallow boxes but obviously now is not
the time to do it we can add them to
swift boxes our boxes
and any other box you like thank you
chairman
thank you council and uh thank you for
your point explanation as well
and uh and around the zoo of birds yeah
excellent uh so moving on now councillor
richardson please
thank you very much chair um in
participating in this debate there are
sort of two main areas i want to touch
upon
um firstly i think we have to
acknowledge that we as many other
councillors have said
we are operating with a series of
planning policies that are fundamentally
out of date
which is already having a detrimental
impact
um on development control within our
district i think council hicks made this
point but i've got
certainly in my in my award i've got two
sites in norton
where we refused permission because they
directly contradicted our
core strategy only to see that
overturned appeal because the
um strategy does not comply with the
nppf
um and we should also recognize the fact
that we have a statutory obligation to
produce a local plan
it's not it's not a choice it's not some
some nicety that we can opt
into um it's obligatory and if we don't
the government will develop one for us
which i think is the last thing that
anyone wants
um however i i will make one point which
i think council
turned touched upon which this shouldn't
be done at the expense of engaging with
our communities
and i i say that because we do have a
very contentious issue in baton
and i have to say it is deeply
frustrating that their emerging
neighborhood plan
was not reflected in fall in the glp
before the most recent publication
um but i know officers are aware of that
and i thank them
for their assistance in the last few
days and i will certainly be following
that up in the
six week consultation um because i do
understand that except the argument
this process has not been flawless as
councillor
may have said i think um but i do
believe that developing
a local plan that is is up to date and
is compliant
um is in our best interest i think not
doing so would put us at a significant
disadvantage
and i think that really cannot be
overstated um and then this
this sort of leads me onto the second
point i want to make because
the purpose of this plan is not just um
for self-preservation um for want of a
better expression
it's about laying out our positive
vision
for our communities and in that spirit
there are two aspects of this plan i'd
really like to highlight um the first is
on healthy communities
this is enormous important we know that
our population is aging
and this presents a significant
challenge with increasing demand on the
health and social care system as people
live longer and live with more complex
health conditions and co-morbidities
and you might ask what's has got to do
with development but as
one key way that we as a local planning
authority can help meet the challenge
is by helping to support independent
living and those with other more complex
care needs
and so in particular i want to highlight
as i think tom did
um policies lp0203
o6 and f7 which promote the inclusion of
residential annexes
extensions to encourage
intergenerational living
as well as bungalows to allow elderly
couples to downsize
along with supported and special needs
housing
all of this will enable people to live
in their own homes for longer
and along with the wellbeing strategy
that we will publish in due course
will help sustain the healthy
communities that we want to see
and the other aspect i want to touch on
very briefly is on the delivery of new
homes
because like i think all councillors i
spend a lot of my time on local planning
matters but the one point i really would
like to make
which does tend to get lost amidst all
of this debate
is that delivering new homes is a good
thing
socially economically in terms of the
sustainability of our rural communities
um in particular as both a conservative
and someone in their mid
twenties who are surprised to be a
homeowner i want us to do everything
we can to support young people and their
families get
on the property ladder which is why i
particularly like to welcome
policy lp08 on affordable housing and
new starter homes
but which is also explicit in saying
this shouldn't be the expense
of rented properties and other social
housing i'm conscious chair i think i've
gone over
my three minutes leave it literally got
across thank you
thank you very much good points and
fairly good timing
okay moving on uh councillor guthrie
please
thank you for that um chair
many of you know i have been on the
member working group cross party and
cross
council assisting officers and members
to get the joint local plan prepared
for full council for debate and approved
for examination with the inspector and
regulation 19.
this iteration started back in 2016
with input from many different members
to those
currently elected along with two
previous rounds of consultations
and jointly over eighteen thousand
representations
members and the public have been avidly
expressing their concerns
and requirements i remember roy barker
in our planning committee
who would always ensure biodiversity was
to the fore
insisting on bird boxes back boxes
hedgehog runs
skylark mitigations and landscape
buffers
were all part of our considerations and
until i came into planning
i didn't realize how many rare crested
newts there were in suffolk
hopefully if regulation 2019 is
completed in spring of 2021
it entitles us to that transition period
before we have to start drafting a plan
which complies with the government's
white paper
and its planning reforms whatever that
might look like
so this joint local plan would buy us
time and any delay now would risk us not
having the plan
lodged and pushes into having to prepare
a white paper compliant plan
and more delay and being chair of
planning i know what that would mean
this plan is not about individual
desires or parochial requirements
planning always has and always will be
non-political
and should not be about my group or your
group
but about the people who live in
mid-suffolk
and mid-suffolk many villages have
neighborhood plans
and they make up part of the jigsaw and
they
need certainty of a local plan
with the policy ls01 which allocates
small
sites in villages hopefully that will
give confidence to smaller builders
who are the backbone of mid-suffolk
employers and not just the large
developers
whilst this is not perfect over 600
pages have been crafted and debated
over many hours and there is scope and
mechanism for supplementary planning
documents
to be included once the plan is adopted
this current joint local plan
demonstrates our collective vision
for the whole of mid-suffolk until 2037
and i will be supporting it thank you
thank you very much we'll move on to
councillor field please
thank you i'll try not to give you a
long lecture on things you know already
um just really pointing out
that uh i see this plan is vital
we absolutely must see the end to being
told that our policies are out of date
not compliant with the mppf we also must
remember that they're literally
out of date they respond to a situation
25 years or so ago
so i will certainly be supporting this
plan it's been quite good working
on working group it's always good i
think to work
across party it generates a diversity of
views
and that diversity of views improves the
decision-making
process greatly it's good to get the
challenges in then
maybe then later on when we're faced
with inspectors
that doesn't mean the fact that i feel
this is a good plan and we need to move
ahead that i haven't got significant
reservations a number of issues
not satisfied some of them fairly minor
my village certainly has problems with
equestrian development which
generates a lot of junk in the
environment
there are things that are much more
significant i think council
geek mentioned a number of those and
she's undoubtedly right about the
long-term sustainability of
our whole thrust and perhaps almost the
thrust of human progress
and we need to continue to work on some
of the issues
the big one that people persistently
repeat is
is the spatial distribution of housing
uh certainly there has been quite a
allocation of houses uh
some distance down the a14 around
walgreens nelms well etc
i'm also so conscious however that uh
any change to that is not without a cost
i live in the ipswich fringe as the
count
council passed more and council
whitehead which represent areas here as
well
um we currently are
accommodating something close to 2 000
houses that's
quite a chunk of the total that must be
provided
um and you know that's in four villages
not a vast number it's it's not a
ipswich is accommodating those houses
it's villages
just on the periphery that are so
i guess there are some difficult
conversations still to be had
but on balance i believe it's the right
thing to press ahead
now get this through its next stages
and make sure we don't get caught by the
next range of government uh
government fantasies perhaps i should
say thank you
thank you carl says some good points
actually um we've now got uh councillor
mansour believe you have a point of
order if you'd like to speak please
yes thank you chair i would just like to
comment
on something that councillor hicks said
um
i felt that he was not respecting
neither mine or nor
councillor geek's decision and and that
disrespect i feel is a little bit
tantamount to bullying
um okay that's noted but a point of
order is for a breach of council
procedures
or law um i don't think it comes in that
it's it was his
uh his comment but um if you'd like to
take it up after the meeting and i'm
sure if it's due that councillor hicks
will not be short in coming forward with
an apology thank you
okay moving on then uh we've got
councillor pratt please
thank you chair um so i would just like
to first of all say
that i welcome the improvements to our
local and strategic policies which aim
at least to safeguard biodiversity and
tackle climate change
however i'm not entirely convinced that
the wording
of our policies with this plan always
provide the teeth at least at the level
needed
to effectively tackle the environmental
challenges ahead of us
i noted that in our climate change
objectives we have an
ambition to be cl carbon neutral by
2030.
um this is not really an ambition as
such is not really in
keeping with the spirit of cl a climate
change emergency like the one that we
declared in 2019
unfortunately ambitions are not enough
to meet the 2030 target
okay sorry we do need to meet the 2030
target
since this is a target that is required
to keep
our planetary temperatures below one
point a 1.5 degree rise
since pre-industrial times above this
threshold
we are entering an era of climate change
that will radically alter our planetary
systems
and lead to environmental chaos failing
to meet
our 20-30 target means that we only have
a 50
chance of staying under the 1.5 degree
threshold
as greta funberg put it leaders
are too often willing to set goals for
the future
but shy away from taking the pain and
making the level of changes needed
desperately at this very moment to
tackle the climate crisis
and i don't need to go over this again
because it's been mentioned by council
of
mountains already that the core of the
jlp
the spatial distribution policy puts too
much emphasis
on housing development along the a14
which does not help us move away from a
car based society
or a consumerist based society
there is also clearly a lack of strength
in or initiative to build passive house
or a very similar heist environmental
standard for new homes
i i really do applaud the hard work of
our offices and genuinely feel that the
cross-party group have really striven to
better the status quo
all within the limitations set out in
the current
nppf however for all the reasons
uh i've given so far i'm
not able to support with very deep
regrets i'm not able to support this
joint local plan thank you
thank you and moving on to councillor
welland please
thank you chair um now i think there's
much to welcome in this plan
but there are policies which i fear will
be detrimental
to some communities there's a real
danger
that villages along the a14 corridor
will lose their distinctiveness
starting to already but this could could
well get worse and accelerate
uh with this local plan yeah i feel the
um
spatial policy will not lead to
sustainable development across the
district
yeah i feel i i feel between a rock and
a hard place
i have to choose between voting for a
joint local plan
which will be devastating for some
communities on the one hand
or voting against it because the future
without a joint local plan is
unpredictable
and could well be worse i will vote for
the
uh for the recommendation but it should
be noted that the council started work
on
this plan many years too late that must
never happen again
staff need to be assigned to working on
supplementary documents
and looking at updating this plan as
soon as the inspector's report
is received thank you chair
thank you councillor welling um moving
on now to councillor turner please
i'm back council that's a misprint
you've already spoken
so uh moving on to councillor casting
please
thank you very much chair um this is a
really great meeting
for me because this is our chance to
actually get this moved on to the next
stage
it's so important to get this local plan
in place
for managing the infrastructure needs of
mid-suffolk
um we mustn't underestimate how
important
it is to um vote for this tonight
the um the evidence base in here
was absolutely fascinating and
absolutely huge
it was just amazing to see all that
information
and it showed me i got a sense of pride
that that's how we deal with that's the
process that we use to deal with
this kind of thing within the um council
it's some
within the planning for mid-suffolk
because
it's it's very much
in touch with what's going on in our in
our area
the um the information just gives us
that tool we need
to put these houses in the place where
they can do the least possible harm and
i'm talking about
um services infrastructure biodiversity
there's so many different sides of this
but that least harm needs to be the
always should be the aim for proper
planning
but the um we can argue
that we shouldn't build because it
it will never bring house prices down
and there's no need
or um whatever really but it comes down
to supply and demand
and um a lack of supply of houses
leaves people sharing with parents
they it leaves them unable to move
unable to pay
and stuck basically and socially we
can't
do this we've got to think about the
future residents
as as well as the current residents
when we make these um decisions so
that's i that's where i am i'd
like you to um support this local plan
um tonight and um yeah
thank you thank you councillor miller
please
thank you chair um without repeating
what my colleagues have said
i'd actually like to make a point about
policy lp 14
actually which is to maintain vitality
and viability of the tone centers
and the proposals include above the
shops
homes and for a mix of retail and other
leisure and cultural activity
including support for the evening
economy and improvements to the public
realm such as tree planting
and green infrastructure i think this is
really important in this day and age
so we do have vibrant town centres not
just in the daytime
but during the evening as well and i'd
like to sort of mention that with regard
to stone market
we actually have got a policy for tree
planting we've actually planted a small
orchard
in the rear of the council offices and
there are plans to to plant trees
across the town in the future i fully
support this plan
and i thank all the officers for the
hard work that they've actually put into
presenting this
this evening including the the working
group and of course councillor byrne
thank you chair thank you councilman
before we move on with debate
uh council hicks your hand is up again
is this a
point of explanation yeah yeah no i mean
can i just say if counselor mancer and
cancer geek felt i bullied them
of course that is not the intention at
all that's not the way i am all i'm
trying to do is point out why i disagree
with their decision
that's all so if i've caused upset to
them i apologize but that's not the
intention
i'm trying to point out why i disagreed
what they said thank you
um my point is it's not
it's not bad to debate it's not bad to
disagree with other people
i don't see anything derogatory in the
comments but
again thank you for coming about the
point of explanation
moving on with debate then uh council uh
councillor
amirosen please
thank you very much chair um
i would again like to acknowledge the
work that's gone into this plan it's a
very impressive body of work and um
and my following comments are in no way
intended to undermine
that effort um
i will support this plan because
i feel the pinch of the looming
amended white paper coming from central
conservative government which will make
it harder to maintain a sensible
planning policy
and may have negative effects
and we certainly need to shield our
district
from that however
i do so with reservations
and remain unconvinced that we're doing
absolutely everything
to ensure that we're adopting a truly
regenerative
approach towards ensuring a holistic
environmentally robust future
thank you thank you some important
points there to be honest with you
moving on then to councillor carter
please
oh yes before i start to apologize for
any background interference my daughter
has been lovely singing voice this
afternoon
um i have to say can i say as well am i
disappointed in
counselor hicks for mentioning
the names of a point that uh it takes
away for some of the
it all all very good uh uh um
to debate but when you mention
somebody's name it takes a point
a point away
my apologies i just wanted myself as
well um
okay um can i just say that
this i'm very disappointed in how the
we've had this all this uh in network
interference
during this meeting it's um
especially with me i've been in and out
of this meeting so far so i've missed
quite a bit of it so it's left me
very it's left me very confused i wish
i want to be at a vote for this i want
for to be a part of through because
this is much needed we need
this plan in place but also
part of the plan is that we've been it's
and it's mentioned that
it's gone as far as current planning
policy will allow
but
i've lost my point complete doesn't
matter um
i can come back to you so just cover
your thoughts i'll come back to you at
the end if that's okay with you
no no you don't need to apologize okay
counselor melon please
uh thank you mr chair and um
i welcome the the robust debate that's
going on
um and uh the contributions from all
people on the on the council
when i was elected a councillor last
year i did not expect that planning
issues would come to dominate my
inbox and my workload and my time in the
way that it subsequently has
and so like other counselors i do crave
the certainty
that we hope will come from the adoption
of this
joint local plan however this does not
mean i'm a wholehearted supporter
of the document i have a number of
significant reservations
despite the amount of work that's gone
into it and uh there is much in the plan
which is good but i do want to briefly
go through my concerns
firstly the number of homes proposed are
based on the government standard
methodology
so that's a combination of of household
growth projections and local
affordability ratios but this i think
presupposes
the that affordability can be improved
in our area by building more homes
and um both the redfern review and the
legwin review have stated clearly
this is not the case building more homes
will not
improve affordability secondly the plan
is based on the foundation of continuing
economic growth
increased housing industry and business
expansion across our
however district now acknowledged by
many economists that perpetual
economic growth is impossible in a
limited
finite system as in where we live
so if the only way forward we can
envisage is by continuing economic
growth that is inherently
unsustainable and well i welcome the
vision set up for mid-suffolk and baby
to become
carbon neutral by 2030
and policies such as lp 25 are very
welcome
i can't see that vision being achieved
if we continue on our existing path
but my main concern is the spatial
distribution as other
uh councillors have mentioned far too
many homes allocated to a small number
of core villages
and i want to use the main settlement in
my ward baton
as an example we're a small village
we're not on the a14
and we're not on the a140 corridor we
don't have a railway station although
the main line goes right
through the village and what bus
services we once had have largely
disappeared thank you suffolk county
council
yet we're apparently a core village
though most people here are totally
dependent on the car
now the allocations listed in the
document give us about 267
homes as well as those we have two other
developments already approved by
committee
so roughly 400 homes coming to backton
effectively doubling the size of the
main body of the village
now that kind of change is not
incremental or evolutionary it is
wholesale change in the size the scope
and the character of the village
and there's something which causes an
immense amount of alarm to residents and
as their elected representative i find
it impossible
to support the plan but i'm also aware
if we don't
that's you just going over three minutes
thank you
thank you chair no problem so moving on
to council scarf please
uh thank you chairman yes i mean like
many others who have spoken tonight we
must have a joke
local plan in place and there are a lot
of good things
in this new local joint plan i think
one of the difficulties for me is we all
have a corporate responsibility as
mid-south district councillors
as many have indicated when they spoke
earlier tonight
but we also have to counter this against
the fact
that we are also there i believe to
represent those in our individual wards
so there is always that conundrum for
councillors
i i would never seek to criticize those
councillors who feel so strongly that
they are
unable to support this joint local plan
i will however be supporting the new
joint local plan
but would stress we have talked much
about housing
but also have to ensure we deliver
sustainable job opportunities close to
those communities too
and that i believe is one of the greater
challenges that this joint
joint local plan will face and indeed is
one
among many other factors on which i
would judge the success of this joint
local plan
if i'm around to see the development of
the plan as it goes through
thank you
thank you councillor scott i hope you
are and uh now moving on to
councillor matthewson please
thank you chair i i can be quite brief i
will reluctantly
be supporting the plan because i know
that the
the government will punish us even more
than it already has with its its
changing um targets and policies
um and processes particularly of
calculating the numbers and so on
but of course i certainly share the
reservations particularly
um from councillor geek on spatial
policy
i think also what council amoroson has
said
and what council of field has said and
so
i will hope that the government will
be tightening up the building
regulations um
far beyond anything that we can insist
on
through using this plan there are many
very nice policies
i like them um but there are these there
are these
fundamental strategic problems so that's
my very reluctant support thank you
thank you council of war boys please
thank you chair um
overall i do think that this local plan
does show vision
and it's much improved on the initial
draft local plan
we saw earlier this year
in particular that it is evidence-based
i recognize the
enormous amount of effort and expertise
that have gone into its production
across contributions from cons cross
council members
and officers and the chairmanship of
councillor burn
i think they've done a really good job
it aims to achieve a balance between not
only protecting
but improving our district's valuable
natural and built
environment ensuring that new
development is delivered in a
sustainable
way whilst also conform with national
planning policy and legislation
i think it does recognize in response
to local housing needs in particular
a growing and aging population and that
gives rise to quite specific demands on
housing
infrastructure services and facilities
and the affordability of
housing we do need more houses we need
more
affordable housing
and this can be met either through
affordable
housing in terms of ownership or
affordable rents
and i have to be convinced whether this
can be so just met
by market forces alone
it does recognize the need to facilitate
business growth and productivity
and recognizes the contribution of the
tourist industry
for baboon bits suffer there's a rec
there's recognized a particular need to
introduce measures that address water
scarcity
and this is something that we can be
addressed
at planet and development committee
level as well
the aims are to ensure sustainable
development i think regenerative
might be a better target because we need
to build back
better it's not just enough to sustain
what we've got but we actually need to
improve
our housing stock and our environment
i have
the two main concerns one is
the tension between local plan
and the emerging and made neighborhood
plans and now
effective consultation has been i think
i work has been done i'm sure
uh but these need to be reconciled
we we don't really need polarization
with regards to development
um so my hopes are that neighborhood
plans will be more to the fore
when considering sites and numbers for
meeting housing needs
and you know get rid of the impression
that sites are allocated without regard
to local
people's inputs and that leads on i
think to spatial distribution which
means my other concern emit suffer the
core villages absolutely
boys i'm sorry uh again you've gone over
your three minutes can i finish the
sentence
uh only if it's very very quick so be
quick
spatial distribution it's effort the
core villagers will be impacted most by
development
brilliant that's quick enough thank you
we'll finally go to
councillor carter please councillor
carter you've got two minutes remaining
so if you'd like to speak please
uh yes thank you very much chair it just
goes to show that uh
i should spend more time writing my
points down unless placating the toddler
by doing the
dog voices um
i i also have to have to thank
councillor gould for actually
mentioning me previously in the meeting
uh clearly he's
more capable of putting one of my points
in a better way than i currently can
so but we do have a democratic duty to
to try to put our uh to try to protect
mid-suffolk for for planning we have
that we need to be able to
look forward to our location
yet this plan doesn't seem to in my case
doesn't
go quite enough it's like being given a
pair of teeth
but being told we're only allowed to use
them to eat soup
um we are
looking for thirsty we are currently
looking to what we are
able to do not saying this is what
to me a plan has to be aspirations and
we should be put saying and writing
this is what we need to do this is what
we need to be able to change
to be able to do so and
we are overlooking projects that we have
done in the past when it comes to
building where we've
we have got um
passive housing products in the past why
can't we
plan that it's this is what we intend to
do
all in future rather than just saying
it should be nice so
i'd i'd love i i probably will be voting
for this
as it is the best what we currently have
but it is with quite a disappointment
that doesn't go it doesn't go far enough
and it's a shame that it hasn't been
done
years previously if it had been it would
have more teeth
than it's now a bit of a
it's been dragged on and lost quite a
lot of the
potential that i had originally great
thank you that's the two minutes
um we'd have loved to waited and heard
all the dog noises but um
sadly we're going to move on so
counselor burn would you like to sum up
please
um yes thank you chairman that's asking
quite a lot of me really isn't it um
that was uh by some margin
probably one of the best um debates that
i have sat through in a mid-south
council meeting
and i do thank all my fellow members for
their contributions to that
um how can i sum it up
what i particularly got from it i think
is that um
there was this regardless of
which side of the chamber you members
sit on
there there was the um a definite
pragmatic
um feeling
that the plan should be supported
and um i accept the
reluctance that some members um
displayed in reaching in in reaching
that conclusion
um it is not possible to please
everybody all of the time
and um it is very rare
that uh perfection in the in these
matters
can can be achieved um
what i what i will say however
is that uh once we have a plan
and i think everybody appreciates the
value of that plan
even even the uh the members who
feel they're unable to support it this
evening
i'm sure we'll concede that there is a
value
to having the plan no matter what
um once we do have that plan in place
i think uh and i was pleased to see
there was cancer
guthrie on one side of the uh
political divide and councillor welum
on the other that were the only members
that actually referred to
reviewing uh the plan once it's in place
and this this is an important this is an
important consideration because
the climate the political climate as you
know not just political
uh little p in our in our grouping but
the big p
um is very volatile
right now we have just had the
government white paper we've had the
changes to the present planning
system which has gone through and is
likely to be
material consideration within a
relatively short time
the planning mic paper reforms may not
come
for several years and let us hope that
they're going to be
considerably modified by the
considerable
uh opposition that some of the rep
representations and the consultation
will have
will have been made to government um
but they are going to change our our
situation
if we get our plan through
we have a period of stability uh we will
not be sitting on those laurels i can
assure you of that
because it will change
and we need to be in in front of it so
almost as as soon as we have this plan
in place
just as we are going to be considering
the
uh supplementary planning documents even
before that
so too will we be considering the review
of the present plan
to try and improve on it
and in order to make it proof uh as best
we can against
the future moving of the goal posts by
government
but we will have to be prepared for that
and
we are best placed being prepared for it
with a plan in position rather than
continuing as we have been so i am
extremely pleased that we've reached
this point this evening
and i thank you all for your
contributions to the debate
but i do urge you um for obvious
reasons i think i've made my position
quite clear
and that you support this plan thank you
very much indeed
thank you councillor byrne and i agree
with you it's been a very good debate
and it's been really really pleasing to
see that everybody has been involved
uh with all their comments and they're
all valuable um
excellent um
this is an incredible detailed piece of
work and uh
the effort the perseverance
and the diligence of all concerns is
deserved of recognition
and i'd like to think that all
counsellors will join me
in thanking all involved for their
diligence
passion tenacity and at times
obviously compromise in developing what
we have before us
i'd specifically like to to
say thank you to councillor byrne and
the cross party member working group
which consists of councillor guthrie
stringer and field to the many
councillors involved in
developing this and assisting the the
working group uh my thanks go out as
well specifically to tom barker
and robert hobbs and the whole team and
i'd like this minute please as a vote of
thanks from the council
so we're going to move on uh to the
recommendations i will read them out
before we go to the vote and the reason
for that is it's been some time
uh listening to that debate since we
actually looked at those recommendations
so these are the recommendations three
point one that the baby and mid-suffolk
joint local plan
pre-submission regulation 19 document
november 2020
appendix a be approved for publication
under regulation 19
of the town and country planning act
local planning england
regulations 2012 as amended
3.2 that delegated authority is given to
the assistant director of sustainable
communities
in consultation with a cabinet member
for planning
to submit the joint local plan
pre-submission regulation 19
document to the secretary of state for
an independent examination
of the modification and procedural
processes
necessary for the examination and 3.3
that the addendum to the statement of
community involvement
november 2020 appendix e
be approved the corporate
manager governance and civic office will
now take
a roll call vote on the proposal
thank you chair can members respond with
either for
against or abstain thank you councillor
morrison
four cancer brewster four
cancer burn four cancer carter
four cancer casting four cancer epinom
four cancer field four
that's the flatman four cancer fleming
four cancer geek abstain
that's the gold four that's a guthrie
four that's a huddingham four
that's a hicks four that's the humphreys
or that's the mansell against
councillor matheson four that's the
melon
abstain that's the mayor four
councillor morley four chancellor muller
four counselor norris four
answer otton four that's a parcel
four that's the pratt
against answer richardson
four cancer scarf four
that's the stringer four
four councillors four
that's a white head four
okay thank you
that's carried out
okay that is carried uh before we go on
to the next agenda point we're going to
take a break for ten minutes
uh so you can refresh yourselves so back
here please
at seven minutes past the hour thank you
come back everybody before we start sir
council pass more your hands up is what
some of you wish to say
um yes there is chairman i don't know
when we come to debate seals whether i
should declare an interest because the
constabulary along with the fire service
has got a live application for the new
um joint police fire station at stone
market
thank you
thank you anyway okay thank you very
much
okay is uh let's should we do rocco are
you happy that everybody is in the
meeting
we're happy that everybody's here okay
before we move on um
obviously under our constitution uh rule
nine we've got the guillotine rule
we're approaching that period of time so
therefore we are going to go to a vote
to extend the meeting
and therefore i'll ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office
to now take a roll call vote on that
proposal
thank you chair if councillors could say
for
against or abstain cancer amoroson
sorry could i ask what are the options
if we don't
vote to extend it we will not be
considering any further business
help our state the meeting will just
conclude will the business be
moved postponed it would be
we would have to m bring that business
forward to the to
another meeting
four and four extending it thank you
councilor brewster four councillor burn
four cancer carter
reluctant e4
that's a gourd four cancer guff three
four answer hattingham four
cancer hicks four councillor humphreys
four councilman mansell councilman
matheson
four councilman mellon four councillor
mayor
or councillor morley four councillor
muller
fort councillor norris oh councillor
otton
four that's the passmore for cancer
pratt
sorry that was a delayed unmuting four
okay thank you
cancer richardson four cancer scarf
or cancer stringer four cancer turner
or cancer war boys four councillor welum
four councillor whitehead four
thank you chair that is carried thank
you that is carried
so moving on now to mc209
community infrastructure levy sill
proposed revised sealed charging rates
for consultation purposes
for baby district council and
mid-separate district council
as sill charging authorities for their
administrative areas
i'd like to invite the council uh
councillor byrne
to introduce paper mc209 and to move the
recommendations in the report
councillor burn
yes thank you chairman um
where am i good um
mid suffolk is a charging authority for
the community infrastructure levy
this we know as sil
this was formally agreed in january 2016
when the civil
charging scheme was adopted
the sill charging rates were agreed
following viability testing
and charging started on the 11th of
april 2016.
it was made clear at the time that rates
were likely to remain for at least
three years so given the position we've
now reached with our joint local plan
it is considered appropriate to formally
review the seal charging rates for both
baber and mid-suffolk
you will also be aware of the new
regulation that now requires us to make
annual returns to the government
by means of an infrastructure funding
statement
our cabinets considered this earlier
this week
mid suffix existing sill rates are given
at
appendix 1 but they are subject to
indexation
annual indexation so the latest index
rates
are shown in the table at paragraph 4.5
in the main body of the report
they represent our current charges
the original installments policy
is at appendix c
following an assessment of the whole
plan viability and potential sill rates
based on infrastructure needs planning
policy requirements and housing
development
marking conditions our viability
consultant
has recommended changes to the existing
sill rates
the revised rates represent an increase
for greenfield residential development
but the evidence provided by our
viability consultant
is that they are reasonable the new
rates distinguish between greenfield and
brownfield sites
and sites where there is an affordable
housing requirement
but are a flat rate in place of the
existing high
and low charging zones
the viability consultants also concluded
that there is no longer a requirement
to operate different rates for the two
councils
they also advised that there is no need
to consider
any sites as having strategic state
status
this simplifies the schedule further
so that all undeveloped sites without
planning permissions
will be still chargeable
the sill member panel has had several
meetings
to formulate the proposals for the
revised sill charging rates in appendix
a
and we're also keen to compare our rates
with those of other cell charging
authorities
these are included at appendix m
while our rates must rely on viability
evidence we were reassured to find that
the proposed rates were comparable
with other charging authorities
proposed revisions to the installments
policy
are in appendix n it seemed reasonable
to review the installments policy
at the same time as the rates review
the member panel supported a simplified
installment policy
which considered the needs of the house
builders particularly the smaller ones
and the parishes who need to plan
facilities
to support community infrastructure
delivery
excuse me your approval is sought for a
six weeks consultation
on all the proposed revisions to run
from the 12th of november
to the 24th of december this is of
course the
same period has agreed for
representations
on the joint local plan details
and council teas are set out at
paragraph
9.1 of mc29
chairman i'm proposing the
recommendations in paragraphs 3.1 to 3.3
of our report
which are for those proposals to be
subject to a six-week
consultation with the responses being
considered
by our viability consultants and fed
into the examination in public
we will then consider the inspectors
report
before adoption on a great on a date to
be agreed
the recommendations are worded for both
baber and mid suffolk but my proposal
relates to us so please replace
both councils at the start of each
recommendation
with mid suffolk district council
on behalf of the members group i would
very much like to thank christine
thurlow and her team
for all their hard work and detailed
analysis
to bring this to you
christine who is professional lead for
key sites
and infrastructure development manager
is with us this evening as is stuart
cook
from our viability consultants
and i sincerely hope that they will be
willing to answer any detailed questions
you may have
so chairman i propose uh recommendations
3.1
3.2 and 3.3 of mc
stroke 20 stroke 9 as amended
and ask for a second thank you
council burn thank you and thank you for
reviewing the recommendations so we're
clear on what we're going to ask
questions upon
do you have a second to please i'd like
to second that uh chair please okay
thank you thank you
we'll now move to questions and debate
counsellors may ask as many questions as
they wish
uh however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion
and must be a question uh when we move
to the debate councillors will
be allowed to speak once and that will
be for three minutes
and will be timed we'll go to the
questions it'll be via the handset
facility and again
there's a technical issue here so i'm
just waiting for that list to come
forward and then we'll get on with the
questions
counselor amoroson your first
thank you very much joe um
i so i understand that we're adopting a
flat rate
um seal charge
um and i want to get a sense of um
whether that is
being increased towards the previous
strategic site rate
or reduced towards the previous
non-strategic site rate um
if that's all possible to answer you
know i just want to get a sense of the
relative
shift that's that may have happened if
we if
ie if we weren't going to go to a flat
rate
what would those two amounts have been
and where is the
where is the new rate in relationship to
those two
fair point council burn if you could
summarize the answer please
uh yes may i may i bring in um
uh christine thurlow here please yeah
please do so
she goes better than i do
so yeah please do so thank you
thank you chair um i haven't turned on
my camera
so i hope that will be acceptable if i
can clarify
can you help me um strategic sites
uh using the definition that we have
used
for
i think we're losing action 106.
sorry they are sites where section one
is
christine you're um christine
we'll have to stop you there you're too
broken so i will come back
um we'll come back to this one towards
the end if you're happy with that please
sure thank you who else can come in to
help if there is any
extra help there um yes if i can assist
to
um chair the question is
is a difficult one to answer because
sill wasn't previously applied
to strategic sites so strategic sites in
the
in the current setup are zero rated for
seal and
all um contributions are received via
section 106
so that's section 106 of the planning
act
and they are kind of bespoke negotiated
agreements that provide for
infrastructure
so strategic sites previously weren't
sill and they are now being brought into
seal
at a general level though what we've
seen is that the previous
rate was 115 pounds per square meter
index linked up to 135 pounds per square
meter so the current
seal charges are broadly speaking 135
pounds per square meter at the high rate
um
and excuse me if i can't recall off the
top of my head
like the low rate at the moment um but
what you see is quite a significant
uplift um being proposed within the
paper
up to 200 pounds per square meter
which should enable us to secure greater
contributions towards infrastructure to
provide what our communities really need
for
so overall there is an uplift but it's
very very difficult to provide a kind of
scientific
approach on strategic sites because each
of those will have been
um specifically negotiated depending on
the
infrastructure requirements associated
with them what
what is can i ask um what is your sense
i know i know it's difficult to answer
what is your sense in in terms of the
new rate
um relating to the two previous the
previously negotiated rates and the sill
my instinct is that the the new approach
will enable the council to secure more
money towards infrastructure
interesting thank you thank you uh
moving on
councillor matthewson please yes
um what what tom bark has just been
saying it goes neatly into what i wanted
to ask about which was that
i i've got quite a big site where we you
know the 106 negotiations are
underway and the application is like to
come to committee
just either just after christmas or
thereabouts
which seems as if it's just about when
the consultation will have ended
and i'm just a bit concerned about how
the um
you know how that's going to be worked
through
um without any disadvantage
because at the moment we've got some
specifics that we want to hang on to
if it gets approved um council matthew
saying i'll just jump in there
um we've got to be careful and this is
to everyone really we don't go down the
minutiae of
our own wards uh and specifically it's
not it's not really the wheelchair
the point is is how it's going to
at the changeover point from from
zero rated um strategic site 106
negotiations
into seal um without
losing anything that's that's you know
nearly agreed
okay just the question tom a quick
answer that please
yes i can come in here so um the
consultation will happen but then there
will be a process of examination on the
the seal charging schedule so it's going
to be
many months before we get to a position
to bring a paper back to council to
adopt
the new schedule um so i think in your
particular circumstance councilor
matheson
there will be sufficient scope for the
negotiation of that section 106 without
it being affected by any changes to the
seal regime
thank you thank you thank you both
councillor warboys please
yes uh this
uh over the last few weeks we we've
looked at consultation
uh about changes to the planning system
uh in particular increasing the size of
developments that
qualify for still payments from 10 to 40
or 50.
um has this been addressed
or risk assessed within this
proposal about changes to the child sell
charges
and the the second bit this question is
i think
it would talk about an in it an uplift
uh do the rate will the rates have have
a significant impact on on
satisfying housing needs in terms of
affordable
housing for rent or purchase
um david i think i think it probably
best if tom carries on
uh answering these because it it seems
to me that that question
um what the the first part of it to
council warboys please was it was to do
the impact to the proposed
changes to the the planning system
regarding
increasing the size of developments that
qualify for sale
payments from 10 to
40 or 50.
these are um uh
increasing the the size of developments
that would affect affordable housing
uh contributions is that what you're
talking about
no the the effect well yes whether they
um
qualify for sil contributions
tom does that affect the sill situation
i don't think it does does it um
so potentially
um it could have an impact and it's it's
not covered within the risks
of the report before you um
but i i think what the 40 to 50
threshold around affordable housing did
won't actually impact on the seal
charging regime that you've got so
what was suggested within the changes to
the current planning system
was referring to capturing affordable
housing
from sites of 10 or more and lifting
that up to
40 or 50. um at present with the current
seal charging schedule we charge
for a single dwelling upwards um so
actually
that i i i fear that you're um
um bringing together affordable housing
and infrastructure contributions into
the same thing so
the changes to current planning system
proposals around
uplift from sites of 10 or more to 40 or
50 was around affordable housing
contributions
not around seal on the second point if
you want a detailed answer i can
i can bring um stuart cooking but in
essence
the the report before you and the the
viability
study that is within the um appendices
and additional
additional items shows that this has
been
calculated in order that um
it is affordable and deliverable so
the the requirement is always that um
seal contributions
and other infrastructure costs and
development costs
come off the land value rather than
increasing house prices for example
because house prices will be led by the
market
rather than the actual um cost of
development
as such if that's not clear i'm i'm
happy to bring
stuart cook in but um if that satisfies
your question
then we can move on i think that's
clarified things for me
i think i was crossing over to two
different things
but the second bit was useful
thank you thank you so councillor phil
please
yes really really the issue of uh uh
we're increasing the yield from seal
which which
uh clearly has benefits um but i was
somewhat
always somewhat concerned about the
motivation to certain providers like the
county council
with education where there seems to be a
strong incentive at the moment to
go for 106 agreements they do that by
insisting on new schools rather than
extending
existing schools so there seems to be a
current
bias there perhaps to a
direction we may or may not want
will this increase tend to reduce that
bias do you think
or will that issue still remain
i'm gonna let you carry on tom
okay i'll um i'll try to do that um
i think it's it's a it's a slightly
complicated question without a kind of
um necessarily an objective answer i
think the the county council and other
infrastructure providers
um often quite like the certainty that
a section 106 agreement provides for
them
um whereas they have to kind of apply to
the councils in order to
receive seal so i think that one of the
kind of
constraints on it is that the the
the authority i guess sits with um the
district council's
cabinet to make the decisions on on seal
payments
um rather than a section 106 which is
kind of separately negotiated and
and to a degree more more certain
um but i mean
the the increase in rates will
potentially draw in more money and
therefore make more available
i'm conscious that infrastructure costs
are rising as well
as we've seen with the county councils
multipliers for delivering new schools
for example
thank you thank you
moving on then to councillor mansell
please
uh thank you chair i i did want to
actually come back
um to uh go back to what council of war
boys was asking about because
with this new charging structure that
we've got it has lots of different
uh categories um and they do refer to
um uh residential development which
triggers affordable housing or not and
it uses that nine dwellings of euro and
the ten
or more dwellings as it's sort of cut
off point
uh for different uh charging regime
and i did wonder after council warboys
has made his comment whether
whether that part of this proposal might
get affected
should the proposals in the planning
white paper
about the size of developments that
trigger affordable housing
are due to increase will we be changing
those numbers in our table
that i believe is on page 25 of my
mod.gov document i've no idea if that's
the same page 25 as everybody else
tom so um yes through your chair
um i think um
first of all it's uh it's important to
recognize that the
um the proposed changes weren't actually
coming through the white paper
and it is important that we separate out
the two consultations that government
over
uh undertook during um september and
october
um so the proposed changes sorry my
mistake
it's just too complicated apology i just
want to
clarify for any of the public that are
watching so the the changes proposed
um from uplifting affordable housing
contributions from sites of 10 or more
dwellings up to
either 40 or 50 dwellings was in the the
consultation on changes to the current
planning system
rather than on the consultation um
planning for the future
white paper and i think our charging
regime reflects our current planning
policies but clearly
if the external environment changes so
if the government do
bring into effect some of what they
consulted on within the changes to the
planning
current planning system consultation
then we will have to very smartly
revisit some of the viability testing
that we're doing as we move into
examination
so it could very well be a point that
that plays out at
examination in due course
thank you thank you councillor passmore
please
uh thank you chairman i think tom's more
or less covered it actually but
i just wanted to check because whichever
way we look at it is a form of i suppose
you could call it a tax on development
and ultimately it's paid by the consumer
because there is no such thing as a free
lunch
um so it's not that i'm against them
seals at all i can quite see there's a
quasi-competitive element compared with
other districts but
one of the concerns i have and i think
you sort of hinted at this tom so sorry
to put you in the hot seat again
if we find for whatever reason things
become unviable
there's a huge economic downturn etc etc
and therefore it starts to impinge on
getting some developments done
we would have the flexibility to revise
it and order it and
i suppose customize it and
to some extent fairly quickly would that
would that be the case
um sorry i'm stepping in i'm conscious
um that questions ought to go through
councillor byrne but he has so sorry
yeah well yeah to run the team
for the next for the next 10 minutes
pretend you're your counsellor burn
there we are
um but still will constantly be kept
under review
and yes we can change it at any time it
wouldn't be
an immediate process because we have to
go through the viability testing and
then an examination in order to change
the rates but we can do that at any time
and we would need to respond to changes
in the market to ensure that delivery
can continue
in order that we can continue to for
example meet the housing delivery test
and ensure that development across the
districts
um isn't stymied good thank you very
much
thank you councillor fleming your
question for tom please
thank you thank you i'm just unmuting
myself
um i have a question really it's a
request for clarification on um
on the viability testing um paper
in terms of um one the
sort of free song that there appears to
be between the section 106
and the sill charging um it seems that
certain um 106
charges make cell charging
unviable for some developments and that
i think that
relationship between those two sources
of funding and if you could just explain
that a little bit
the other thing that concerned me was
the fact that
um it seems that brownfield developments
are generally less viable than
greenfield council fleming um
the first one was a question this is now
breaching approaching into
uh debate so please leave that to the
debate and
tom if you'd like to answer the question
please
um uh yes i feel would
feel a little on the spot here because
there is a a
complicated relationship i guess between
section 106 and
community infrastructure levy one of the
benefits of recent changes to the
legislation is that
they've removed some of the kind of
complexity around the relationship
between them
and we we can we can review at any time
but section 106
is really for capturing um
site specific and where it is required
in order to
mitigate impact seal is really a kind of
generic charge across the piece to
ensure that
infrastructure to support the plan led
development
is captured in full um i think council
fleming that
to really kind of go through the detail
of the
the intricate relationship between
section 106 and still we may need to
have a conversation outside of the
meeting
that's that's fine i'm just more than
happy to do i just wanted to query that
in in terms of the viability which i
think is terribly important
especially in relation to the plan going
forward
and if if counselors would like a
detailed um
response to that i can seek to bring
stewart in who
from our consultants aspen already
undertook the the viability testing
i think in all honesty we're probably
going a bit too far
so um hopefully that's your question
answered to the level it needs to be
answered tonight
please take up that offer with tom post
this meeting i will take that up with
tom
outside this meeting thank you thank you
moving on then we've got um
second one now for councillor morrow
sent please
hi thanks jim um i'm afraid i'm going to
just touch on this
this 106 issue again if i understand it
correctly
you you were saying earlier that um
the fact that strategic sites are now
going to be under a flat
sill rate does that mean that 106
is gonna um be superseded
is is that no longer going to be a a
method of
charging for development
um no it it doesn't mean that it will be
removed so section 106 will still be
used
where it is appropriate to do so and and
one of the things that we need to
remember i guess around section 106
is that it is also a mechanism for
controlling non-financial contributions
so for example affordable housing
mix and tenure and the way that cascade
mechanisms work
would still be captured within a section
106 because
seal doesn't provide a mechanism in
order to do that
one of the changes that the changes to
the
legislation have brought in is is to
remove
um there was a phrase when still first
came in that some of you may be familiar
around
double dipping um which was that there
was a
constraint against using section 106 and
seal for the same infrastructure so for
example if your seal charging
schedule allowed you to collect sill for
bus stops then you weren't able to use a
section 106 in order to capture
contributions towards bus stops
but you can now use section 106 to
secure contributions towards
infrastructure
even if items are fundable via sale
my particular concern is that
sorry councilor morrison do you have
another question i do yeah sorry so
formal question please yeah well yeah so
my concern is that i have personal
experience of
106 being used elsewhere
for um functions other than
infrastructure so for example
um like behavior change projects
um and if if we're going to be saying
we're reducing
the uh amount that's being collected by
106
then is how will that impact
where where will money come from for
those kind of projects rather than just
uh infrastructure projects so so um
you would still be able to use section
106 for those kind of things so that
might be where you're
for example encouraging modal shift um
within
within transport environment or
something like that and you're securing
money in order to
leaflet a place or flower a place or
make information available around
bus routes or around cycle networks or
those kind of things
and section 106 is still a mechanism to
be able to
do that provided that you could evidence
that
securing those benefits
is necessary to mitigate the impact of
that particular development
so section 106 is not disappearing and
it and it can still be used and it will
still be used
where there is evidence from particular
technical consultees whether that's the
highway authority or
or public health for example or the ccgs
we can still use section 106 to capture
some of those benefits
will 106 be reduced under the new regime
the use of 106 will continue under the
new regime
will the um resources of 106 be reduced
under the new regime
um excuse me if i don't
fully understand what that question will
will 106
um i've got to jump in here we've got to
remember what we're here for and what
the recommendations that are that we're
asking questions on
and that is basically moving this
forward consultation that's the primary
aim
we can get into the nitty gritty of sil
and s106 and everything else
i think we got a bit too far i think
he's answered the questions that need to
be answered
and therefore i am going to move forward
next person counselor ek penang please
uh sorry chair i think um actually that
uh
tom has answered my question in response
to the other questions that he's been
dealing with so
i don't have any other questions
okay i can see no other hands up so we
are going to move to debate
again oh sorry i've got councillor well
i'm sorry it's not on my list but i'll
cancel well
please
thank you chair um
unfortunately is a question about
section 106 and and seal but
i think it is relevant to the debate
currently if a development of a
strategic site in one parish requires a
highway improvement in a neighboring
parish
can part or all of that cost be funding
funded from a section 106 agreement with
the developer
in the first parish of the uh deciding
the first page
um and will will such will funding for
such an improvement be more difficult to
achieve
if there are no strategic sites
and will there be a way of to ensure
that such an improvement is funded by
that developer
top um sorry so so there is no
constraint within section 106 that
limits
contributions to within a particular
parish boundary um
if the impact is felt across a wider
area then the mitigation needs to be
applied to a wider area
and so a section 106 can still secure
that um
apologies could you just remind me of
the
latter part of your question basically
is
will that will that continue um even
though
when there are no institutions strategic
sites will that continue
and does it apply to education and
library provision as well as to
for instance highway improvements
section 106 will continue to be used so
there is nothing within the changes that
are before
you within this report that removes the
ability to
use section 106 so you can we
currently enter into section 106
agreements on non-strategic sites
as well as on strategic sites and under
the new environment
we would still be able to enter into
section 106 agreements
on any site where they were appropriate
and necessary
thank you thank you councillor field
please
thank you um a question
on the viability before really or on
issues that
are shown by table 613 in that report
uh i think tom barker uh suggested that
the um still monies effectively
are subtracted from land values
and i noticed looking at the land values
they vary dramatically but but looking
at parts of berries and edmonds and
parts of woodbridge
which seem to be the closest perhaps to
us i see values of about
260 000 per acre
still at the new rates of 200 pounds per
square meter
for a 90 square meter house would be
what 180
000 pounds would suggest the residual
land value would be
virtually zero or certainly would be
agricultural land prices
i wondered what impacts that is going to
have on
the availability of land and therefore i
had delivery of houses
if someone says i've misunderstood i'll
be quite happy
tom i guess if it's okay um
chair would it be appropriate to bring
stewart in on on
on this um question yes please
stuart okay hi there
um so in certain
the um seo rates
um we've had regard to all of the costs
in terms of
all the proposed policy in the draft
local plan
um and um
making that calculation against uh as a
suitable land value
um um the the ppg is clear that
uh i think this leader to their um
land by land-based must reflect all
development costs including
um uh future policy costs if we're
testing against
um drug forces in the local plan um but
but also one certain a suitable land
value it needs to
provide a competitive uh an incentive
for the landowner to release the site as
well
so in certain the land value on the
greenfield basis we've had regard to
the methodology which is the existing
use plus premium so we
first of all set establish used faithful
greenfield which was agricultural
and then applied a suitable premium
which was
which is around sort of 10 times um
and and then that produced a gross land
value of about 100k
85.95
to sell um
so it satisfied that that box so we
shouldn't uh start with development
we've not sought to depress the lambos
too low in certain
the seal or any uh policies
um so it's we
tried to strike that balance between
making sure there's still a competitive
return for a landowner and making sure
that local authority can
um extract as much possible in terms of
policies and still charge as well
thank you thank you just your table
would imply that uh
in two out of the four sites i'm i'm
looking at
um land value would essentially reduce
to zero and
those two sites wouldn't come forward
clearly so
so i think you're looking at the the so
so
is is this in relation to the the the
brownforce sites
uh it's table 613 i was looking at
i i could it's talking about residential
development land at uh
woodward suffolk red lodge barristan
edmonds perkins way tostock
turnpike road berries and edmonds
okay yeah so but so um you're looking at
yeah so so that's
um quest reference looking at the actual
quotient prices of
of of land value remember that's what's
being sought in the market at the moment
um and and quoting prices not
necessarily what um land will sell for
um
and there'll be different drivers in
terms of releasing those sites
um we are looking at the plan growth
going forward within the plan
and and the proposed allocated sites and
the ppg is clear that
land value must reflect more policy
costs so
we would see a a depressive effect until
some of
some of those quoting prices there um
are going forward to reflect all new
policy costs plus
the enhanced still charge
thank you thank you
okay we're now going to move to debate
and as we said before
everybody can speak you have three
minutes and it will be timed
and we'll go through the hands up
mechanism so
the person with the hands up goes first
i'll just wait for that list to come
forward
counselor amber rosen
thank you chair um
so i think i think my question to tom
was relevant and i just want to um
flesh that out a bit because it it does
impinge on
um my decision uh in this debate in this
vote um so
the fact that we're getting rid of um
strategic site negotiation which
contributes to
106 means that
all the money is going to seal now sell
is a less flexible
fund um which can only be used for
infrastructure
and 106 has more flexibility and that it
can be used for
educational projects behavior change
projects which can be very effective in
mitigating uh climate effects
and environmental effects so i
i'm confused as to where we stand on
that and
i i'm just in a state of sort of
confusion about about the uh
specifics of that but maybe i'm wrong
no that's what debates for um it's your
opinion it's your debate
you can say whatever you whatever you
feel um we're going to move on to
counselor scarf please
thank you chair yeah um i mean i i
welcome the lower charges on brownfield
sites because i think this will help us
to get these built out
rather than greenfield sites which has
got to be preferable
with the site-specific sites moving to
sell payments from section 106
for the parts of which they do not
currently have permission
i am however rather concerned that
developers will quickly move to applying
for permission
prior to us being able to implement the
new charging scheme where they will pay
seal because there's an obvious
advantage to them to do so
and the consequence of that is that
parishes like mine here in stone market
could be affected adversely if this
happens
because of course they won't benefit
from the increased charges
as the the sites will then still be
liable under section 106
so the parish won't benefit from the
seal contribution that they get from the
district and nor with the district and i
think
this is one of the potential problems of
of moving site-specific sites to to
to sell and i think um i think we will
suffer because
obviously they've only got to apply for
outline permission uh and then it's in
the process
and we will have to use section 106 as a
means
which i feel it puts us a bit of a
disadvantage here in stone market in
particular
no thank you uh councillor mounts all
please
thank you chair um i i uh as part of the
um
uh seal working group um i i have uh had
several discussions
about this uh proposal and i i will be
supporting this
um i'd just like to first of all commend
mid-suffolk and baber um as i think they
are
um ahead of other councils
in their sil strategy um both the
charging procedure and the the way it's
to be spent and i think that this uh
this review of the charges is uh is
timely
um because um there is an uplift of
costs and
and we hear a lot about the cost
multipliers um
so i do welcome the fact that we're
looking at these charges
um and we are changing the way that
we're we're going to be collecting the
money
um in response to um both uh
councillor morrison and councillor
scarf's concern about the
the change from strategic sites um no
longer
being um zero sill rated and having uh
section 106
maybe i'm wrong but i think that there
are uh
all but two of those um strategic sites
that were in the old
system uh have already got
outline planning permission so um
it isn't it isn't that we're talking
about the vast majority
of the strategic sites they were that
they'd got their outline permission
anyway
uh and and giving councillor scarf's
comment some consideration
whenever you're going to change the
system there will be a cut off date
and there'll always be that problem that
people will rush in and try and
get things done whichever side of the
cut-off date
they think is going to be the most
beneficial to them
and i don't think there's anything we
can really do about that if we're going
to change a system
we're going to have to cut off some time
um
i also think that um i i've just got one
tiny dispute to make with i think it was
councillor byrne who said when he made
the proposal
that we're having a simplified structure
i actually think this slot might
be slightly more complicated because we
have such a range of different charges
on
on different categories of land but i do
welcome
the the uh proposal which is is aiming
to encourage more development on
brownfield sites over greenfield sites
by having having the
the low rate um and the other thing i
did want to say is about the
installments
policy um again the aim of changing this
installment policy
is is trying to um make sure that our
smaller developers
are not are not inconvenienced too much
we still want that want them to pay
obviously um
and we are also need to be mindful of
the ceiling on sill receipts for parish
councils
we did have some discussion about some
of the large very large developments
which can if the installments are paid
too
uh close together could kick some um
parishes
over there up to their sill cap
counselor i'm sorry you've gone over
sorry sorry i'm waffling i'm terribly
sorry
i will be supporting it i think this is
a timely thing to do
um so thank you you're doing very well
thank you
okay there are no more hands up for
debate
so therefore counselor burn would you
like to sum up please
um yes thank you chairman um
i can only say how pleased i was that
they there was this happy
happy coincidence that were two other
members of this meeting
that would also call david byrne um
because i would have been a bit lost
without them
so thank you very much david and david
um how to sum up on this one
uh it it's it's very difficult partly
because
as you um no doubt surmise
the technicalities of it are very
complex and
uh i'm not as familiar as the the
experts the
the toms of this world uh and the
christine's it's unfortunate that
pope christine was not able to
contribute to this
because she is an absolute mine of
information
and i'm sure she would have been able to
cast a lot of light on some of the
things that were
confusing people however i do believe
it's the uh
the the proper move to be making and um
i i am um very pleased
that counselor mantle also feels that
that's the uh
that that we are going in the right
direction with this
so all i can say about what way of
summing up is that yes please
uh do do support it i do believe it's
the
right thing to be doing and and the
right time to be doing it
thank you
thank you councillor burn um yeah
there's a stack of work going on here
and uh you know
it's an amazing document actually when
you when you read through it
so i'd like to thank you councillor bert
for all your work uh tom christine and
stuart also for your assistance tonight
and obviously in the in the hard work
has gone behind this
this total report and of course for the
cross party working group
yeah good effort um so we're now going
to move on to the recommendation
i will read it out because it's been a
while so
recommendations 3.1 that mid suffolk
district council
approves the content of this report and
all appendices
with a view to agreeing that this
material be the subject
of a formal consultation for a period of
six weeks
between the 12th of november and the
24th december
2020 this would be a separate
consultation but run in parallel with a
consultation exercise
for the emerging joint local plan 3.2
that mid suffix district council agree
that all responses to the consultation
relating to revisions to the rates of
still charging
will be considered analyzed by the
council's viability consultants
and taken into account and fed into an
examination
in public to be held by an inspector
mid-suffolk district council also agreed
to fully consider the inspector's report
when the examination in public is
concluded together with any consequent
inspectors report
issued with his or her findings to both
councils
this would allow both councils to
consider outcomes
together with any revision and
subsequent adoption of any new revised
seal charging rates
for both councils together with an
implementation
date the corporate manager governance
and civic office will now take a roll
vault
on the proposal thank you chair if
members could reply with four against or
abstain
councillor amaroson four
councillor brewster four councillor
byrne
paul cancer carter four
cancer casting four cancer epineuron
four cancer field four that's for
flatman
four councillor fleming four
councillor geek four councillor gould
four that's a guthrie four cancer
hattingham
four cancer hicks four councillor
humphreys
four councillor mansell four chancellor
matheson
councillor mellon four that's the mayor
councillor morley councillor muller
four councillor norris or councillor
otton
four cancer passmore full chancellor
pratt
four councillor richardson four
cancer scarf oh that's a stringer
or answer turner or cancer warboys
four chancellor willem four and
councillor whitehead
paul
okay that is carried thank you for your
contribution tonight it's been excellent
really good debate
and thank you for all the officers and
staff for making it run so seamlessly
in the background it's appreciated the
meeting is closed the next meeting is on
the 26 november
2020 and god willing we'll see each
other then take care
thank you
you